ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE.
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. A REAL.
ARAMBULA A HAND BERMAN HELLO
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH BONTA BRO
BURKE CALDERON RIO CERVANTES
CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU CHOI
KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DE. DAILY DE EGGMAN
FLORA FONG USER FRIEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON
GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK. WORK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEAM
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
THAT OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER. WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VINCE FONG THIS FALL. A MEMBERS
PLEASE LET ME IN PRAYER. DEAR
LORD DURING TIMES OF SUFFERING
INFLECTION YOU ALLOW US TO SEE
OUR PRIORITIES MORE CLEARLY. IN
THIS TIME OF GREAT DIFFICULTY%
IN OUR STATE AND OUR NATION WE
CALL OUT TO YOU FOR HELP.WE
NEED WISDOM DISCERNMENT AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY GREATER LOVE
FOR YOU AND OUR NEIGHBORS
PLEASE PROVIDE US THE COURAGE
WE NEED TO DENOUNCE AND JUSTICE
TO UPHOLD WHAT IS RIGHT TO
FIGHT AGAINST WHAT IS EVIL
PLEASE GIVE US HUMILITY. FIRST
TO LISTEN AND THEN TO
UNDERSTAND SO THAT COMPASSION
MAYBE THE ROOT OF ALL
ACCOMPLISHED IN THIS CHAMBER.
DURING POWER COMES FROM YOU. IN
HIS MERCY NOW WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GATHER INTO WORK
ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA. MAY ALL WE DO
REFLECT YOUR LOVE AND GRACE AND
MAY WE REMEMBER DEPENDENT. SEE
TO ACCOMPLISH YOUR MOST HOLY
WELL YOUR NAME IN YOUR NAME WE
PRAY AMEN. THANK YOU MISTER
FONG WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS TO REMAIN STANDING AND
JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GABRIEL.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
IS THERE ARE. THANK YOU YOU MAY
BE SEATED. READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JUNE ELEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY THE CINEMATIC NINETY ON
THE AUDIBLE KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEMPORE THE
ASSEMBLY PRESIDING SEE PROXY
PARKER THE DEFICITS CLICK DAVID
BOWMAN READING THE ROLES COLSON
MEMOREX MCCORKLE THE SIMPLY
MOTION ON ON CALDERON MOVES.
AND MR FLORA SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
QUESTION FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR MEDICAL LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER AS
WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY
VOEPEL. AND FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CHOI WEBER
HOLDEN DAVID CHIU GONZALEZ
GABRIEL GLORIA CALM WATER JONES
SAWYER MULLIN GIPSON
ROBERT RIVAS DAVID CHIU TING
FRIEDMAN AND WOOD TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN MEMORY TODAY. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND THE RULES.
TO ORDER THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS TO THE FIRST DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR I DON'T NUMBER
SIXTEEN ACR WHEN HE THREE
MULLIN ITEM ONE SEVENTEEN ACR
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
BOERNER HORVATH. ITEM ONE EIGHT
THIS USING ITEM EIGHTEEN H. R.
EIGHTY NINE EGGMAN. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. ACROSS UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX SIXTY THREE TO WITHDRAW SB
ONE EIGHTEEN AND SB ONE
NINETEEN FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW SOMEONE
REVERTING. TO TAKE UP THE BILL
TODAY WITH A REFERENCE TO FILE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF THIRD
READING. MR FLOOR PURPOSE SIR
WITHHOLDING ASKING SAN REQUEST
ROLL CALL VOTE. MR FLORA IS
WITHHOLDING. MOVED BY MISTER
CALDERON SECOND BY MISTER TANG
ON THE RULE SUSPENSION MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. IT IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AN I. IN MISTER FLORA NOW.
WE
ARE WAITING TO MAKE EVERYONE
MAKE SURE EVERYONE IS KEYED IN
AT THIS POINT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY
FIVE. KNOWS TWELVE THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. MISTER CALDERON
YOU ARE AGAIN RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION THANK
YOU MISTER BEFORE I DO THAT
PROCEDURAL MOTION I JUST WANT
TO ALSO REMIND ALL MEMBERS AND
ASK ALL MEMBERS THAT WHEN
YOU'RE ON THE FLOOR PLEASE KEEP
YOUR MASK ON ALSO WHEN YOU ARE
SPEAKING A- MICROPHONE. I TAKE
YOUR MASK OFF LEAVE YOUR MASK
ON TO SPEAK TO THE MICROPHONE
SIX OF THE WORST TIME TO TAKE
OFF YOUR MASK SO IF YOU COULD
PLEASE FOLLOW THAT RULE. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT THE NEXT MOTION
IS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER TO THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE
BRADFORD IN SB THREE NINETY SIX
HERTZBERG FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. AND SB FIFTY
TWO PAN FROM THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH A BE THE ORDER. QUESTION
NUMBER FOUR PLEASE MOVE ITEM
TEN A. B. NINETY FOUR BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO THE INACTIVE FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW ME TO TAKE
UP HR ONE HUNDRED TODAY WITHOUT
REVERSE THE FATHER THE PURPOSE
OF ADOPTION. MR FLOOR FOR
PURPOSE SIR. WE WILL HOLD YOU
NOW STINSON THAT'S ROLL CALL
WHO. MISTER FLORA IS WITH.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES. AND
MISTER KING SECONDS. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE ON
SUSPENSION OF THE RULES THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
AND HI VOTERS YOUR FLOORS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I. MR
FLORA AND NO THIS TAKES FORTY.
OKAY. WELL CLOSER ALL. I TWENTY
FOUR KNOWS THIRTEEN MOTION
CARRIES THE RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I MOVE TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY ROLES SIXTY THREE AND
SEVENTY EIGHT TO MOVE ITEM A.
SEVENTEEN A. B. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY AND ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B.
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR FROM THE
ENACT A FILE TO ALLOW THE BILL
TO BE TAKEN UP TODAY WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. AS A FLORA
MAY. MISTER FLORA. THE US
FIGURE HOUSEHOLD NELSON'S
ENOUGH FOR ROLL CALL VOTE. MR
FLOREZ WITHHOLDING UNANIMOUS
CONSENT MISTER CALDERON MOVES
MR TANG SECONDS ON THE ROLL
SUSPENSION MEMBERS AGAIN THIS
IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND MISTER FLORA I KNOW
THE- MISTER CALDERON TESTING
FOR NINE. MR FLORA AND NO. ON
THE PROCEDURAL MATTER. WELL
CLOSE ROLE TELL YOU WHAT I
FORTY FOUR KNOWS TWELVE. THE
RULES ARE SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO BUSINESS
ON THE DAILY FILE. THIS IS
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS THIS IS BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE SECOND READING FOR
GREAT SENATE BILL NYE WITH HIM
AT SEVEN NINETY FIVE THE
MEMBERS SAY NINETY NINE WITH A
MEMBERS SIMPLY WITH A MEMBERS
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THE METS TOLD
MANY TIMES A MINUTE SENATE BILL
NINE FIFTEEN AND SENATE BILL
NINE FORTY. ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO BE TAKING UP. A COUPLE
OF BUDGET ITEMS AT THE TOP.
THIS IS MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE
BE MINDFUL OF THE VOLUME LEVEL
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ON THE FLOOR WHICH
WILL BE. A CRUCIAL FOR GETTING
THROUGH TODAY'S BUSINESS AND
WILL BE ENFORCED. PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF YOUR PHYSICAL
DISTANCING RULES MEMBERS THIS
IS WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE.
SENATE BILL ONE EIGHTEEN
CORPORATE. SENATE BILL ONE
EIGHTEEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW AN
ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION OF
FORCE TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BE RELATED TO THE BUDGET MISTER
KING BUT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THIS BILL ISN'T AN
AMENDED VERSION OF OUR PUBLIC.
SAFETY TRAILER BILL THAT WE
RETURN TO THE SENATE IN. IT
DOES NOT INCLUDE THE POLICY
RELATED TO JUDICIAL DISCRETION
FOR MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION OR
ELDER PAROLE IN THE MAN'S THAT
THE BAND THE BOX PROVISION TO
NARROW ITS APPLICATION. WITH
THESE THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
POLICE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION HAVE
REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. THE REMAINING BILL HAS
SEVERAL PUBLIC SAFETY
PROVISIONS REFLECTED IN THE
BUDGET PACKAGE WE PASSED IN
JUNE. IT JUST A PAROLE TERMS TO
TWO YEARS FOR DETERMINATE TERMS
IN THREE YEARS FOR AN
INDETERMINATE TERMINAL ALSO FOR
THE PRODUCTION'S BASE ON IT
HURTS TO TERMS OF PAROLE.
REQUIRES THE IDENTIFICATION OF
A STATE AND OPERATED PRISON FOR
CLOTURE IN TWENTY TWENTY AS
WELL AS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE IT
INCREASES LEASE REENUE BOND
ALL FOR HEALTH CARE FACILITY
APPROVAL PROJECTS THE CDC ARE
REQUIRES THE STATE PUBLIC
DEFENDER TO PROVIDE TRAINING.
AND ASSISTANCE TO PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES OF COMPLEX
MATTERS ALSO ALLOWS FOR THE
EXPANSION OF REMOTE COURT
APPEARANCES AT CDC OUR LIMIT IS
THE INTEGRITY THE INTEGRATED
SERVICES FOR BATTLE MENTALLY
ILL PAROLEES PROGRAM. PROVIDES
OF THE DEFINITION OF A
CORRECTIONAL PHARMACY IT
INCLUDES CHANGES TO ALLOW FOR
MORE EFFICIENCY AND SAFETY. THE
BILL ALSO UPDATE THE DEFINITION
OF AN ASSAULT WEAPON IN A JOB
THE BERMAN PAGE HI MY- FROM
JULY FIRST FOR FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY THE RESPONSE TO CONCERNS
RAISED BY THE DENTIST OFFICE. I
WITH THE I. FIVE THINGS CHANGE
OBERNOLTE RECOGNIZE THIS JUST I
RISE IN OUR TO ASK ONE EIGHT
THIS BILL EXT THE RELEASE OF
CRIME FROM CAL STATE PRISONS.
MOST NOTABLY IT REDUCES THE
LENGTH OF SUPERVISED PAROLE
FROM THREE YEARS TO TWO YEARS
IN MOST CASES IN FACT IN THE
MAJORITY OF CASES PAROLE BE
SHORTENED TO ONLY TWELVE
MONTHS. THIS BILL ALSO
ELIMINATES THE ABILITY FOR THE
STATE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
TO RETAIN SUPERVISION OVER AN
OFFENDER EVEN AFTER THE BOARD
HAS GOOD CAUSE FOR DOING SO.
COLLEAGUES THIS BILL WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OF THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS THAT
WE REPRESENT I ORIGINAL VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OVER NOTHING
MS KAMLAGER GOV YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE. THEN I AND THEN
I RISE TO SPEAK. TO SB ONE
EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW I USUALLY
RARELY SPEAK ON BUDGET BILLS
BECAUSE THEY COME WITH DOLLARS
AND IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
FUND THESE CRITICAL PROGRAMS
BUT I DO WANT TO. TALK ABOUT TO
ALARMING ELEMENTS IN THIS BILL.
THE FIRST IS THE- IRRESPONSIBLE
DRAFTING AFFECTION A FIVE ONE
POINT NINETY THREE BE RELATED
TO. ARREST RELIEF GRANTING. AND
YOU KNOW WORDS ARE IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY WHEN. DEALING WITH
PUBLIC SAFETY. THEY REPRESENT
DISTINCT LEGAL ACTIONS AND
EVENTS AND DISTINCT LEGAL
CONSEQUENCES. AND I'M SPEAKING
TO THIS ISSUE BECAUSE YOU
CANNOT BE ACQUITTED IF YOU HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED YOU CAN ONLY BE
ACQUITTED. IF YOU'VE BEEN
FORMALLY CHARGED NOW I KNOW
THAT THIS IS A SMALL ISSUE. BUT
IT IS IMPORTANT. AN ARRESTEE
DOES NOT MAKE YOU A DEFENDANT
UNLESS YOU HAVE BEEN FORMALLY
CHARGED. AND IT IS IMPRUDENT TO
CO MAIN GOAL THESE TERMS. I
MENTION THIS BECAUSE THE
INTERCHANGEABLE NATURE OF THE
WORDS. IS LAZY BUT CAN ALSO BE
CALM CONFUSING AND PROBLEMATIC
TO THE CONSUMERS OF THIS POLICY
AND THE CONSUMERS ARE OUR
JUDGES ARE ATTORNEYS ARE
DEFENDANTS ARE PROBATION
OFFICER. AND THE PUBLIC YOU
KNOW INTERPRETATION IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT TO RELY
ON WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE'S FREEDOM SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT SOMEWHERE ALONG THE
LINE. THAT KIND OF CLARITY CAN
BE ADJUSTED THE SECOND MORE
AGREED JUST ELEMENT FOR ME IS
THE MOVE TO PERMIT ELECTRONIC
PRELIMINARY HEARINGS AND TRIALS.
YOU KNOW THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE DEFENDANTS. CHARGED
WITH. OFFENSES THAT COME WITH
FULLY AND CONSECUTIVE
SENTENCING. THAT CAN RESULT IN
DOUBLE DIGIT TIME SERVED IN
PRISON LIKE FORTY FIVE YEARS
FIFTY YEARS SEVENTY FIVE YEARS
THAT WE WOULD ENCOURAGE THEM TO
PUT THEIR DUE PROCESS IN THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT ON THE
LINE BY ALLOWING THEM TO AGREE
TO TELEPHONE AND VIRTUAL
PRELIMINARY HEARINGS. IS
DERELICT TO BE NICE. MANY OF US
ON THIS FLOOR HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO UNRAVEL THE ASSEMBLY LINE
THAT IS OUR CAR FEDERAL SYSTEM
AND THE GLIMMER OF HOPE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE. IS WHEN WE STOP TO
HAVE LIVE TRIAL WHEN THE JURY
AND THE JUDGES AND THE
ATTORNEYS CAN LOOK AT EACH
OTHER WHEN YOU CAN LOOK AT
MOVEMENT AND I. AND SHARE
STORIES WE'D LIKE TO BELIEVE
PROBABLY SIX THOUSAND MILES TO
COME UP HERE BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO TALK ABOUT
BILLS HIM PERFECT. SIX
AUTOMATICALLY GO TO INDIA BUT
WE'RE HERE. DEBATING POLICY.
AND I JUST THINK WE HAVE TO BE.
QUESTION ABOUT PUTTING THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT AND DUE
PROCESS ON THE LINE OR EVEN
TRYING IT OUT THE WINDOW. IN
ORDER TO CREATE SOME. BECAUSE
OF COVERT. NOW I'M GOING TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE
THERE ARE GOOD THINGS ABOUT.
THE PAROLE. THE PUBLIC DEFENDER
TRAINING THE CLOSING OF THE
PRISON AND YOU CERTAINLY DO NOT
THROW THE BABY OUT WITH THE
BATHWATER. BATHWATER'S LOW
MURKY. AND SO I'M GOING OVER
THIS BILL AND I'M AN URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO THE SAME I
WANT TO SAY TWO DEFENDANT OUT
THERE. IF YOU HAVE COUNCIL.
THAT SUGGESTS. THAT YOU ALLOW
YOURSELF TO HAVE. A VIRTUAL OR
TELEPHONIC HEARING. OR TRAIL
WHEN WE HAVE OUR OWN PROBLEMS
KEEPING OUR KIDS THROUGH ONLINE
LEARNING OR EVEN HAVING OUR OWN
SO MEETINGS IF YOU HAVE COUNCIL
THAT DO THAT. YOU FIND THAT
PERSON IMMEDIATELY AND RUN
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT HAVE YOUR
DUE PROCESS AND THEY DO NOT
HAVE YOUR CIVIL LIBERTIES IN
MINE- THIRTY. AND I WOULD ASK
AND SUGGEST THAT MAYBE WE DON'T
EITHER IF THIS IS A LINE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO
DOWN BUT I URGE AN AYE VOTE. ON
SB ONE EIGHTY. THANK YOU MS
KAMLAGER DOES. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ADAM CERTAMEN CLOSE WE
WISH. WITH THAT. THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. IS THAT ABOUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY THREE.
DOES ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO FILE. MISTER.
CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE SIR
YEAH JUST AS A CLIFF ON TALKING
POINT NUMBER SEVEN AND
REFERRALS TO RULES COMMITTEE
JUST TO BE CLEAR- I SAID SB
THREE SIXTY NINE I HERTZBERG
NOT SB THREE NINETY SIX BUT SB
THREE SIXTY NINE HERTZBERG. THE
CLERK WILL NOTE. THIS IS
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE SB
ONE NINETEEN CORPORATE. SENATE
BILL ONE NINETEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW AN ACCOLADE THE STATE
EMPLOYMENT MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FORCE TO
CONNECT IMMEDIATELY BE RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. MISTER CHENEY
AGAIN OFTEN THINK ABOUT SPEAKER
SB ONE NINETEEN IS OUR SECOND
AMMO YOU TRAILER BILL THE BILL
DOES TWO THINGS A RATIFIES THE
PAYMENTS BETWEEN THE STATE AND
BARGAINING UNIT TWELVE THE
CRAFT A MAINTENANCE WORKERS ARE
POLLS BARGAINING UNIT THIRTEEN
THE STATIONARY. ENGINEERS
RECEPTOR THE JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET DEADLINE
THE MIX CONFORMING STATUTORY
CHANGES TO NINE OF THE
BARGAINING UNITS A DENTED
BURDEN TO PRIOR JUNE. TWENTY
TWENTY TO SISTER WITH A. B. ONE
NINE THE FIRST TIME ARE YOU
BILL PASSED. IN JUNE THESE MO
USE REFLECT THE SAVINGS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET ACT. IN CONFORMED
ACTIONS WE TOOK IN OUR JUNE
PACKAGE I RESPECT FOR YOUR OUT
FRONT OF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHANG MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB ONE NINETEEN. THIS TRAILER
BILL IMPLEMENTS MO USE WITH A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT STATE
BARGAINING UNITS THAT WILL
RESULT. IN MINOR SAVINGS TO THE
STATE. UNFORTUNATELY THEY ALSO
MAKE CHANGES THAT WILL RESULT.
IN POTENTIALLY FAR GREATER LONG
TERM LIABILITIES TO THE STATE.
THEN THE MINOR SAVINGS THAT
WERE REALIZING. I'LL GIVE YOU A
COUPLE OF EXAMPLES THE FIRST
EXAMPLE IS THAT THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS A FULL PROGRAM FOR
STATE EMPLOYEES BUT UNLIKE THE
TRADITIONAL FOR WILL PROGRAM.
THIS BILL COMPENSATES STATE
EMPLOYEES FOR FULLER DAYS BY
ADDING THOSE DAYS TO A PERSONAL
LEAVE PROGRAM IN THAT
EMPLOYEE'S NAME. THE THAT WE
BALANCE CAN BE CARRIED FORWARD
IN PERPETUITY. AND WHEN IT IS
PAID OUT AT THE END OF
EMPLOYEES TENURE WITH THE STATE
IT'S PAID OUT AT THEIR HIGHEST
SALARY NOT AT THE SALARY AT
WHICH HE WAS GRANTED. SO THIS
IS IN EFFECT NOT A COST SAVINGS
TO THE STATE BUT A HIGH
pINTEREST ALONE AT THAT WE ARE
TAKING FROM OUR STATE EMPLOYEES
TO FINANCE OUR BUDGET DEFICIT
THIS YEAR. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A
RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING. CAN BE
FOUND IN THE FACT THAT THIS
TRAILER BILL SUSPENDS. THE
EMPLOYEE CONTRIBUTION FOR POST
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS FOR A
NUMBER OF STATE BARGAINING
UNITS. NUMBER REMIND YOU THAT
WE HAVE A HUGE UNFUNDED STATE
LIABILITY. KHLOE RETIREE HEALTH
CARE ALONE. WE HAVE AN UNFUNDED
LIABILITY OF ABOUT EIGHTY SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. SOSA SPENDING
THAT IS ONLY GOING TO MAKE THAT
UNFUNDED LIABILITY PERSIST IN
THE FUTURE. THIS TRAILER BILL
WILL RESULT IN RELATIVELY
MODEST SAVINGS TO US THIS YEAR
ABOUT FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
MILLION WITH AN M. OUT OF THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT I FEAR THAT
IT WILL CAUSE FAR GREATER HARM
TO THE STATE LONG TERM BY
INCREASING THOSE LONG TERM
LIABILITIES AND CONSEQUENTLY
MAKE IT EVEN HARDER FOR US TO
RECOVER. FROM THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
ON COLLEAGUES I ORIGINAL VOTE.
FAMOUS FOR OBERNOLTE SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM. MR TENNEY MAKE
CLOTHES WE WISH. THANK YOU FOR
SPEAKER WELL FIRST LET ME JUST
TAKE THE TWO BARGAINING UNITS
THAT HAVE THEM I USE PROF
ORDERED AS WELL AS ALL THE
DIFFERENT BARGAINING UNITS AS
YOU ALL KNOW WE HAD A VERY
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET DEFICIT.
WELL WE ASK MANY OF THOSE
BARGAINING IT ALL THOSE
BARGAINING UNITS TO STEP UP TO
THE PLATE TO SACRIFICE TO DEFER
COMPENSATION TO ENSURE THAT WE
COULD TO SCORE THOSE SAVINGS
THEY ABSOLUTELY STEPPED UP. BUT
IT WAS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT IN IS A VERY LARGE
SACRIFICE ON THEIR OWN AND- ONE
OF THE FOCAL THEM URGE ALL OF
YOU TO VOTE FOR THIS BECAUSE
THESE ARE COST SAVINGS. THAT
WERE CODIFIED IN OUR BUDGET TO
REALLY HELP US BRIDGE OUR
DEFICIT WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS PEOPLE
NINETEEN I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO
ASK FOR IMMEDIATE. TRANSMITTAL
TO THE SENATE MISTER SPEAKER
FOR TO ASK YOU MEDIA TRENDS ON
SB ONE EIGHT AS WELL. THANK YOU
MISTER TANK AND WITH THAT THE-
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS.
IS THAT A VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. YEAH. YEAH. THE
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS FIVE. THAT MEASURE PASSES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE ON
SENATE BILL ONE NINETEEN AS
WELL AS IMMEDIATE TRANSMITTAL
OF. SB ONE EIGHTEEN. THE
PREVIOUS MEASURE. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE SENATE.
THIRD READING FILE SENATE THIRD
READING. THIS IS FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. FIVE AND TWENTY SIX.
SB. FOUR TWENTY THREE.
CORPORATE SENATE BILL FOR
TWENTY THREE BY SENATOR UMBERG
ANOTHER'S NATALIE INTO
ELECTIONS AND CLEAR OF YOURS
AND SEE THEIR OF SIGNIFICANT
MEDIALLY. MR BERMAN EMAIL WITH
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES THE NOVEMBER GENERAL
ELECTION IS JUST OVER NINETY
DAYS AWAY YEAH WE STILL DON'T
KNOW WITH CERTAINTY HOW KOBE
NINETEEN WILL BE AFFECTING US
AT THAT TIME DUE TO AB EIGHT
SIXTY EVERY REGISTER CALIFORNIA
BORDER OR SEE THE BALLOT IN THE
MAIL PROVIDING A SAFE
ALTERNATIVE VOTING IN PERSON.
THAT MANY VOTERS. EITHER CANNOT
OR CHOOSE NOT TO USE THEIR VOTE
BY MAIL BALLOT. FOR EXAMPLE
MANY VOTERS WILL NEED TO USE
ACCESSIBLE VOTING EQUIPMENT OR
ON THE LANGUAGE ASSISTANCE.
HOMELESS AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
VOTERS MAY NOT RECEIVE THEIR
MAIL BALLOT. OTHERS WILL LOSE
OR DAMAGE THEIR BALLOTS AND THE
REPLACEMENTS. IN ADDITION
ELIGIBLE PEOPLE NEED SOMEWHERE
THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE UP TO
AND ICLUDING ON ELECTION DAY
ITSELF. SB FOUR TWENTY THREE
ENSURESTHAT EMPLOYMENT EARLY
IN PERSON VOTINGOPPORTUNITIES
ARE AVAILABLE. IN A MANNER THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE AND
REQUIREMENTS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY RECOGNIZING.
THAT COUNTIES MAY FISCAL
NINETEEN RELATED CHALLENGES
WHEN IT COMES TO PROVIDING
POLLING PLACES OR VOTE CENTERS.
THAT WAY THEY HAVE IN PRIOR
ELECTIONS. PARTICIPATING
COUNTIES WILL HAVE TO PROVIDE
AT LEAST ONE VOTING LOCATION
FOR EVERY TEN THOUSAND
REGISTERED VOTERS FOR FOUR FULL
DAYS. STARTING THIS SATURDAY
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION AND ONE
DROP OFF LOCATION FOR EVERY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND REGISTERED
VOTERS FOR THE MONTH LEADING UP
TO THE ELECTION. COUNTIES
WISHING TO PARTICIPATE YOU MAKE
A VALID EFFORT TO COMPLY WILL
BE ABLE TO SEE PERSONAL WAIVERS
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE. IF
THEY ARE UNABLE TO OBTAIN 1100%
OF THE REQUIRED VOTING SITES OR
DROP OFF LOCATIONS. KEEP IN
MIND THAT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ARE OPTIONAL FOR THE
COUNTIES. IF A COUNTY WOULD
RATHER RUN THEIR ELECTION AS
THEY HAD PREVIOUSLY THEY ARE
FREE TO DO SO. EITHER WAY THEY
MUST STILL MAIL EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER ABOUT. BEFORE
TWENTY THREE ALSO REQUIRE STATE
AND VOTER EDUCATION AND
OUTREACH CAMPAIGNS. REGARDING
THESE NEW PROCEDURES. AS WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN AND SOME OTHER
STATES. A MASSIVE REDUCTION IN
VOTING LOCATIONS WOULD RESULT
IN LONGER LINES AND LARGER AND
POTENTIALLY UNSAFE GATHERINGS.
ON ELECTION DAY. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE ONE FOUR THAT WE WILL NOT
THAT WILL NOT BE THE CASE IN
CALIFORNIA. SB FOUR TWENTY
THREE SUPPORTER. STATE
ADVANCING JUSTICE AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS OTHER CIVIC
ORGANIZATIONS IT HAS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN FOR IMMEDIATE
TRANSMITTAL FOR THE SENATE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN MR
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AS YOU KNOW. MY
COLLEAGUE AND I HAVE WORKED IN
A VERY BIPARTISAN. FASHION TO
ENSURE A SAFE AND FAIR ELECTION
IN NOVEMBER I MUST PART WAYS
HOWEVER ON THIS BILL. MY
COLLEAGUES. STANDARD VOTING FOR
THIS BILL YOU ARE VOTING TO
LIMIT VOTING OPTIONS AFTER THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION. WE HAVE
ALREADY ACTED IN A BIPARTISAN
FASHION TO ENSURE THAT PEOPLE
CAN SAFELY VOTE BY MAIL. WELL
WE DID THAT A FEW WEEKS BACK
RIGHT HERE IN THE IN THESE
CHAMBERS THE LEGISLATURE ACTED.
AS WE KNEW WE COULD TO RESPOND
TO THE CRISIS AND WE PROVIDED
THAT OPTION COOL. NOT NOW. IF
PEOPLE DECIDE NOT TO VOTE BY
MAIL. SHOULDN'T EXPECT THAT
THEY CAN AT LEAST GO IF THEY
NEED ASSISTANCE OR OTHERWISE
SHOULD WE EXPECT THEY CAN AT
LEAST GO IF THEY'RE INTO. A
REGULAR COUNTY. THAT THEY CAN
GO TO THEIR PRECINCT THAT
THEY'RE USED TO GOING TO WONDER
THIS BILL THAT PRECINCT. MAVOR
NOT BE THERE. AND ON DAY OR IF
YOU'RE IN A VOTER CHOICE.
COUNTY THE YOU WILL HAVE TEN
DAYS. TO GO TO A VOTE CNTER TO
GET ASSISTANCE OR TO VOTE IN
PERSON OR IF THERE'S SOME
REASON WHY YOU NEED TO. GET
THAT IN PERSON ASSISTANCE.
UNDER THE UNDER THE STATUTE ON
THE RULES YOU HAVE TEN DAYS TO
DO THAT NOW UNDER THIS BILL
VERY LIKELY THREE DAYS. FOR YOU
TO GO IN THERE AND IN A IN A
CODED CRISIS SITUATION. WHEN WE
WANT TO PROVIDE AS MANY OPTIONS
FOR PEOPLE TO VOTE IN PERSON SO
WE DON'T HAVE. CROWDS AT
PRECINCTS AND AT BOTH CENTERS
UNDER THIS BILL VERY LIKELY
WILL HAVE THE OPPOSITE. THOSE
ARE THINGS THAT YOU SHOULD
REALLY BE THINKING ABOUT- AS WE
TAKE THIS MEASURE UP. MOREOVER
THIS GOES ALONG WITH THE SAME
EXECUTIVE ORDER NONSENSE THE
GOVERNOR PUT OUT THERE WHERE HE
LEGISLATED INSTEAD OF ALLOWING
US AS AS WE'VE ALREADY SHOWN
THAT WE CAN DO OPEN THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO ITS JOB AND
BASS LAW THE GOVERNOR ONE OUT
THERE AND DID IT. BY EXECUTIVE
ORDER. AND THIS JUST CONTINUES
TO GO ALONG. WITH THAT PROCESS
WHICH IS COMPLETELY BACKWARDS.
WE NEED TO SEND A MESSAGE THAT
NO THAT'S THAT'S NOT OKAY. AND
WE ALSO NEED TO STAND UP FOR
VOTING RIGHTS OPTIONS. FOR OUR
CITIZENS WHO MAY VERY WELL NEED
TO GO. TO THE PLACE THAT
THEY'RE USED TO GOING THERE
VOTING PRECINCT A VOTE CENTER.
UNDER THIS BILL. I THINK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A LOT OF VOTER
CONFUSION AND WE COULD VERY
WELL HAVE VERY PROBLEMS IN THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION- DON'T JUST
DO A PARTY LINE VOTE ON THIS
MEMBERS I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
REALLY THINK ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND I WOULD ENCOURAGE ABOUT
THANK YOU. FIGURES GALLAGHER
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM. MR
BERMAN. I APPRECIATE I AGREE
WITH ONE THING THAT MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM NICHOLAS SAID WHICH
IS THAT THIS SHOULD NOT BE A
PARTISAN PARTY LINE VOTE WELL
DESERVES BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THE REALITY IS THAT WERE TRYING
TO OPERATE ELECTION UNDER A
GLOBAL HEALTH PANDEMICS. THE
REALITY IS THAT ALL OF OUR
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS THEY USED
TO OPEN UP THEIR GARAGES FOR
POLLING PLACES MIGHT NOT BE
COMFORTABLE. OPENING UP THE
GARAGE IS FOR POLLING PLACES
THIS NUMBER. YALLA THE IT IS
NOW ALL THE PEOPLE TO. POLL
WORKERS ON ELECTION DAY TIRED
NUMBER THE DUKE MUCH TO SOME
DEMOCRACY SHOULD NOT BE SERVING
AS POLL WORKERS THIS NOVEMBER
THE REALITY IS. WE ARE NOT
VOTING UNDER NORMAL TIMES WE
ARE VOTING UNDER PANDEMIC THAT
TESSA TATE'S I DIFFERENT PERSON
SAFE EVERYBODY TO BE ABLE TO.
THIS BILL IS THE ACT OF. ONE
SEVEN. LET STATE. ARE COUNTY
ELECT. AS FOR THE STATE. THIS
IS THE US TRY TO IGNORE OF THAT
ARE COUNTY ARE GOING TO HAVE A
TOUGHER TIME FINDING THOSE
VOTING. SO HOW CAN A SYSTEM
THAT PROVIDES S. PLACE IN
PERSON BUT I NOT. THE
COMPLICATIONS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE FACING IN NOVEMBER
AND I MUST SAY IT'S- A BIT.
CUTTING OFF YOUR NOSE TO SPITE
YOUR FACE MAKING THE ARGUMENT
THAT WE SHOULD KILL LEGISLATION
BECAUSE WERE MAD ABOUT AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER. WE SHOULDN'T
KILL LEGISLATION GOES UP ABOUT
A WATER WHICH PASSED ALLEGES
GEN. BEFORE YOU TODAY. ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK BERMAN AT WITH
THAT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE-
MEMBERS. SARAH ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THAT ABOUT. MEMBERS
THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR. ON THE
URGENCY.
ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE OF.
ALL MEMBERS LED
IZZARD OF A. MR BERMAN MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE A FILE I'M TWENTY
FIVE. ON SEVEN THIRD READING
THIS IS SENATE BILL. THREE
SIXTY FOUR. OPERATE SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTY FOUR BY SENATOR
MITCHELL ALCALINA TAXATION TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY TAX
LEVY. MR TANG EMAIL BUT- THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER SB THREE
SIXTY FOUR WOULD EXTEND THE
CURRENT TAX EXEMPTION OFFERED
TO SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS. ON
COMMERCIAL PROPERTY IF THE
PROPERTY IS REASSESSED BECAUSE
PROPOSITION FIFTEEN PASSES THIS
NOVEMBER. OPPOSITION SEVEN
WHICH WAS PASSED IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXEMPT SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS
FROM PROPERTY TAX IN ORDER TO
INCENTIVIZE CLEAN ENERGY UNDER
CURRENT LAW THIS EXEMPTION IS
IN PLACE FOR SYSTEMS INSTALLED
THROUGH. TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. AN
UNINTENTIONAL DRAFTING ERROR
IMPROPER FIFTEEN REMOVE THE
CURRENT EXEMPTION THIS BILL
WOULD FIX THAT PROBLEM WOULD
ENSURE THAT THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS THAT WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY COULD STILL BE
RESPECTED. FOR THAT IF THERE
WAS A CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP. OF
THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
EXEMPTION UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR. AS YOU WILL RECALL THIS
POLICY WHICH WAS PASSED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY SUCCESSFUL
WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF MOVING
TOWARDS 1100% RENEWABLE ENERGY
FOR OUR ENERGY CONSUMPTION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE WE
RECENTLY JUST INSTALLED THE ONE
MILLION FOR ROOF HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL. AND SO OUR
POWER. TO ENCOURAGE A SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS HAVE BEEN AND
ACCESSIBLE ONE WE DON'T STOP AT
NO MATTER. ROGER I BUILT ON ITS
THREE FOUR. THANK YOU MISTER
TANG. SEEING THE OLD MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM.
CLARK LIBERAL. IT IS SAD BUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS ARE ESERVER.
MR
TANG MOVES A CALL. I MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO.
CONCURRENCE. THIS IS CONCURRENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. AB. EIGHT
FOURTEEN SIXTY BY DR WEBER. THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
FORTY SIXTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WEBER AND AN OUTLET AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
DOCTOR WEBER S. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBRS I RISE TODAY- TO BRING
YOU BACK AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR
CONCURRENT AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
DELAYING IMPLEMENTATION. BILL
HOW. BY FOR THEM BOTH SIDES OF
THE HOUSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON KIND THE
FOURTEENTH. THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER SEEN NOTICE. OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. LOCAL OF THE ROLE.
DESERVE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF A
RESERVE VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLED HER OF ALLIES FOR
ONE NO NINE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I AM
PREPARED TO LIFT THE CALL. ON
FILE ITEM TWENTY SIX SB FOUR
TWENTY THREE. CARPOOL POSTS.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THEM
ALL MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
WELL. PARK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL
YOU VOTE AS FIFTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHT ON THE URGENCY EYES FIFTY
SIX KNOWS EIGHT ON THE MEASURE
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION AND MEDIA
TRANSMITTAL TO THE SENATE. AND
NOW MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LET THE CALL OF FIVE TWENTY
FIVE SB THREE SIXTY FOUR. FOR
PROPOSED. THE RESERVATION- ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL. CULTURAL TIED
UP AS FIFTY SIX. KNOWS EIGHT.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS OF
THE REFERENCE THE FILE. OKAY.
THIS IS H. R. ONE HUNDRED BY
MISTER CALDERON BROKERAGE HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
RELATIVE TO THE LEGISLATURE
MISTER CALDERON EMAIL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER HR ONE HUNDRED
CHANGES THE ASSEMBLY RULES FOR
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY LEGISLATIVE SESSION TO
ALLOW MEMBERS TO VOTE FOR
MEASURES ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
VIA PROXY VOTING HR ONE HUNDRED
IS A VERY NARROWLY TAILORED A
MEASURE THAT ACKNOWLEDGES IN
ADDRESSES THE VERY REAL
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY MEMBERS
FOR THEIR AND THEIR FAMILIES
HEALTH AND SAFETY DURING THESE
EXTRAORDINARY TIME. IT'S OUR
ONE IT IS INTENDED TO BE.
THAT'S FROM COVERT NINETEEN OR
LIVE WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE IN THE
HIGHER RISK CATEGORIES THIS
MEASURE IS LIMITED TO THIS
LEGISLATIVE SESSION OR UNTIL
THE TERMINATION OF THE COPA
NINETEEN STATE OF EMERGENCY.
WHICHEVER COMES FIRST EARLIER
WE PASSED A CA TWENTY FIVE THAT
IS A MUCH BROADER AND PERMANENT
CHANGE TO HOW THE LEGISLATURE
CONDUCTS ITS VITAL BUSINESS
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY.
ACA TWENTY FIVE REQUIRES A VOTE
OF THE PEOPLE AND ADDRESSES A
WIDER RANGE OF SITUATIONS SUCH
AS A PANDEMIC. NATURAL DISASTER
WAR OTHER SITUATIONS THAT WOULD
REQUIRE A STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND LIMIT THE ABILITY OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO MEET AND DO ITS
WORK HR ONE HUNDRED IS A
NARROWER. AND FOCUS SOLUTION TO
OUR CURRENT PANDEMIC THE
FOLLOWING WILL BE THE MANNER IN
WHICH A MEMBER WILL BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE. NEW PROXY VOTING
PROCEDURES ASSEMBLY UNDER HR
HUNDRED A MEMBER MUST SUBMIT A
LETTER TO THE SPEAKER
REQUESTING PERMISSION TO VOTE
BY PROXY. OUR CAN AT A SAMPLE
TEN. WHEN IT THERE IS A CAN IS
LET INTO THE FOR FLOOR SESSION
DAY AND I'M- MUST SUBMIT A NEW
WORK. FOR DAY. THEY WISH TO
VOTE VIA PROXY. ONCE APPROVED
THE MEMBER WILL DESIGNATE THEIR
PROXY ONLY THE FOLLOWING FOR
MEMBERS WILL ACT AS PROXIES THE
SPEAKER THE MAJORITY LEADER
REPUBLICAN LEADER AND THE
REPUBLICAN FLOOR LEADER. THE
NUMBER THE MEMBER WILL NEXT
PROVIDE A LETTER WITH VOTING
INSTRUCTIONS THE CHIEF CLERK
THE LETTER WILL DESIGNATE THE
FILE ITEM BILL NUMBER AUTHOR
MOTION OR AMENDMENT IF
APPLICABLE AND THEIR VOTE. THE
LETTER IT SHOULD BE SUBMITTED
NO LATER THAN FIVE PM THE DAY
PRIOR TO THE SESSION THEY WISH
TO BE VOTING VIA PROXY. AT THE
BEGINNING OF EACH SESSION THE
PRESIDING OFFICER WILL ANNOUNCE
THE MEMBERS WHO ARE AUTHORIZED
TO VOTE BY PROXY FOR THAT
SESSION. NAMES OF MEMBERS
APPROVED VOTING ALSO BE POSTED
ON THE WEBSITE TO SESSION ONCE
AN ITEM IS TAKEN UP. THE
DESIGNATED PROXY WILL THEN WHAT
THEN PHYSICALLY GO TO THE
MEMBERS DESK AND FOLLOW THE
DIRECTIONS LISTED IN THE VOTING
INSTRUCTIONS AND OPERATE THE
VOTING SWITCH. MEMBERS WILL BE
EXPECTED TO WATCH THE SESSION
AND IT'S DEBATE. IF AFTER THE
DELIBERATION ON A BILL THE
MEMBER CHOOSES. TO CHANGE THEIR
VOTE VOTING INSTRUCTIONS ON THE
ITEM THEY CAN EMAIL THE CHIEF
CLERK THE NEW VOTING
INSTRUCTION A SPECIAL EMAIL
ADDRESS WILL BE PROVIDED TO THE
MEMBER. TO ENSURE TIMELY
RECEIPT OF PUTTING INTO. THIS
EMAIL MUST. LEAVE PRIOR TO ROLE
BEING OPEN ON THAT ITEM. A
MEMBER VOTING VIA PROXY. MAY
NOT CHANGE OR ADD ON TO A VOTE
ONCE THE VOTE IS ANNOUNCED. THE
CHIEF CLERK WILL VERIFY THE
ACCURACY OF THE VOTE AND WILL
KNOW THE PROXY VOTE IN THE
ASSEMBLY JOURNAL. THE APPROVED
LETTERS REQUESTING PRIDE PROXY
VOTING WILL ALSO BE. INCLUDED
IN THE JOURNAL. BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS IN SEVERAL STATES HAVE
ADOPTED PROXY VOTING PROCEDURES
H. R. ONE HUNDRED AS FAR
LIMITED AND TRANSPARENT. THAN
ANY OF THE OTHER PROCEDURES
IMPLEMENTED AND THE UTILIZED
ELSEWHERE IN ORDER TO CONTINUE
TO DO THE PEOPLE'S WORKWHILE
ALSO PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR MEMBERS WE MUST
PASS HR ONE HUNDRED. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
CALDERON. MR KILEY YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TODAY WE NEED AS THE
STATE ASSEMBLY A LEGISLATIVE
ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY DEFINED AS A
COMPANY A PERSON'S COLLECTED
TOGETHER IN OE PLACE. YEAH
WE'RE CONTEMPLATING RIGHT NOW
AN UNPRECEDENTED AND UNLAWFUL
DEPARTURE FROM THAT
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS.
THE FIRST THING TO NOTE ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL IS THAT IT'S
COMING ONLY TODAY ON AUGUST
THIRD AFTER THE ASSEMBLY HAS
RECESSED FOR TWELVE OUT OF
FIFTEEN WEEKS. A PROXY OR
REMOTE VOTING LEGAL WHY DON'T
WE DO IT MONTHS AGO SO WE COULD
HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA THIS WHOLE
TIME. INSTEAD FOR TWELVE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT WEEKS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY. TWELVE WEEKS
IN THE EYES OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
RUN THIS CAPITAL. WE DIDN'T
MEET IN ANY MANNER AT ALL. WE
DIDN'T SHOW UP. SO WHY IS IT
THAT WE'RE CONSIDERING THIS NOW
WILL ONE ANSWER WAS ALLUDED TO
BY THE MAJORITY. WHICH IS THE
EIGHT TWENTY FIVE DIDN'T MAKE
IT THROUGH THAT WAS THE LAWFUL
WAY TO ESTABLISH PROXY VOTING
IF WE'RE GONNA DO IT. WAS A
REQUIRES APPROVAL BY THE SENATE
AND A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE HOUSE
RESOLUTION. REQUIRES NEITHER OF
THOSE THINGS. IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE A MORE WILLFUL
VIOLATION OF THE CONSTITUTION.
BY THIS BODY BUT YOU DON'T NEED
TO TAKE MY WORD FOR. YOU CAN
TAKE THE WORD OF THE SPEAKER OF
THE ASSEMBLY. HE TOLD THE
SACRAMENTO BEE ON APRIL SIXTH
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS WITH
REMOTE VOTING. ON APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH. A SPOKESPERSON FOR THE
SPEAKER PUT OUT A STATEMENT
SAYING QUOTE WE BELIEVE THAT
THE CONSTITUTION NECESSITATES
THE PHYSICAL PRESENCE OF
MEMBERS TODAY. AND PROVIDES THE
RIGHT FOR THE PUBLIC TO ATTEND
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS IN
PERSON. THIS IS BEEN A LONG
STANDING OPINION OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL'S OFFICE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
REQUIRES PHYSICAL PRESENCE FOR
LEGISLATOR VOTING AND THAT
POSITION WAS AFFIRMED IN A MAY
ELEVENTH OPINION BY THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL. WHICH SAID
THAT VIRTUALLY ALL THE
PROVISIONS OF ARTICLE FOUR OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
ASSUME THAT THE LEGISLATURE ACT
BY MEANS OF PHYSICALLY
CONVENING MEMBERS IN THE SAME
PLACE. AT THE SAME TIME. SO
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF WE
PASS THIS RESOLUTION AND
PROCEED WITH PROXY VOTING WELL
THAT'S GOING TO CAST A CLOUD.
OF UNCERTAINTY OVER EVERY
SINGLE BILL THAT WE PASSED
BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF
SESSION. AND AGAIN YOU DON'T
NEED TO TAKE MY WORD FOR THAT.
POLITICO REPORTED ON APRIL
THIRTIETH. THAT THE ASSEMBLY
SPEAKERS OFFICE. FEELS THERE'S
A DIFFERENT TYPE OF RISK THE
POSSIBILITY OF A LAWSUIT
CHARGING THE REMOTE NOTES
VIOLATE THE CONSTITUTION. IF
SUCH A CHALLENGE FOR FILED AND
PREVAILED RENDON'S OFFICE
REASONS LAWS PASSED REMOTELY
COULD BE THROWN OUT. AS IF
THERE WEREN'T ENOUGH
UNCERTAINTY AHEAD OF US IN THE
COMING MONTHS. HAVING
POTENTIALLY DOZENS OR HUNDREDS
OF BILLS WITH AN UNCERTAIN
LEGAL STATUS IS SOMETHING OF
THAT OUR STATE SIMPLY CANNOT
AFFORD. BUT MY BIGGEST
OBJECTION TO THIS PROPOSAL. IS
THE PROXY VOTING IS SIMPLY
INCOMPATIBLE WITH.
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT AND
THIS AGAIN IS PART OF OUR
LEGISLATOR COUNCILS MAY
ELEVENTH OPINION WHICH STATES
NOT ONLY DOES REMOTE
LEGISLATING CONTRADICT THE
COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WORDS USED IN THE CONSTITUTION
BUT IT RUNS COUNTER TO HOW
DELIVERED OF BODIES HAVE A
STORE HISTORICALLY BEEN
UNDERSTOOD. TO OPERATE.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
LEAST REPRESENTATIVE
LEGISLATURE BY ANY MEASURE IN
THE COUNTRY. PROXY VOTING WOULD
DO AWAY WITH THE ONE THING THAT
KEEPS US A DEMOCRACY IN MORE
THAN JUST NAME. WHEN YOU HAVE
PROXY VOTING THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR DEBATE FOR
DELIBERATION TO HAVE YOUR MIND
CHANGED TO CONSIDER ALTERNATIVE
POINTS OF VIEW THE VOTE. IS PRE
COOKED. HERE'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DIRECTOR
FOR THE ACLU SAYS. THIS IS ONE
OF THOSE SITUATIONS WHERE YOU
HAVE TO ASK IF THE CURE IS
WORSE THAN THE DISEASE WHAT
DOES IT MEAN TO OPEN THE DOOR
TO SUCH DRAMATIC DEPARTURES FOR
MORE DEMOCRATIC DEMOCRATIC
TRADITIONS. AND IS IT WORTH IT.
NOW I FEEL FOR THE MEMBERS WHO
CANNOT BE WITH US. BECAUSE OF
ALL OUR ABILITY TO THIS VIRUS.
IT'S A LOSS FOR THEM IT'S A LOS
THEIR CONSTITUENTS BUT IT IS NO
MORE OF THE LOS THEN
LEGISLATORS WHO FOR A CENTURY
AND A HALF AND HAD TO MISS
SESSIONS BECAUSE OF INJURY.
ILLNESS OR OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE
THIRTY SECONDS. AT THE END OF
THE DAY ARE VOTES ARE NOT OUR
PERSONAL PROPERTY. THEY'RE NOT
TRANSFERABLE THEY'RE NOT OURS
TO GIVE AWAY THE VOTES ON THAT
BOARD DON'T BELONG TO US. THEY
BELONG TO THE PUBLIC THAT'S THE
WHOLE IDEA. OF POPULAR
SOVEREIGNTY. WE ARE MERE
STANDINGS. BUT THAT REQUIRES US
TO ACTUALLY STAND IN AND IF WE
DON'T THEN THE ENTIRE CONCEPT
OF REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
BREAKS DOWN SO I ASK YOU. TO
USE THE VOTE THAT'S BEEN
ENTRUSTED TO YOU TODAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN. THE
FIGURES KILEY SAYING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE HR MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY CLOSE I APPRECIATE MY
COMMENT THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ROCKLIN I WILL
JUST SAY THAT THE COURTS HAVE
CONSISTENTLY RECOGNIZED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE SOLE
AUTHORITY TO GOVERN ITS
INTERNAL AFFAIRS AND TO ADOPT
RULES FOR ITS PROCEEDINGS- WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. STATE ALL AROUND AND
WITH THAT. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS OF
UNDECIDED VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE SERVO.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TYLER. HIGHS FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS TEN THE REST IS
ADOPTED. ON THE FILE FILE ITEMS
TEN. THROUGH. TWENTY TWO. PASS
AND RETAIN. MR GLORIA HAS
AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE SB FOUR
SEVEN NINE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CORPORATE WITHIN
THEM SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
NINE WITH THE MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA MISTER
GLORIA THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
FOR SEVENTY NINE ON BEHALF OF
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM. THESE
AMENDMENTS ADDRESS THE RECENT
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE CITY O
CORONADO CAL CHANCE IN THE
UNITED STATES NAVY TO
RELINQUISH VELVET PORTIONS OF
STATE ROUTE SEVENTY FIVE IN
STATE ROUTE TWO EIGHTY TWO IN
THE CITY OF CORONADO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER WARREN. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION. WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILLS OUT TO PRINTED BACK ON
FILE. AND FILE ITEMS TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY SEVEN ALSO PASS.
EVERY CHANGE. MEMBERS PURSUANT
TO ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT TWO I RE REFER IN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS A. B. THIRTY
THREE THIRTY CALDERON TO THE
BUSINESS AND FOR.
MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO HOLD OFF ON A SEVENTY
SEVEN POINT TWO REFERRAL. AT
THIS TIME. WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE UP ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS. THE ONE YEAH.
BEGINNING WITH MISTER CALDERON
C. A. B. THIRTY THREE THIRTY.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
CORPORATE WITH A MEMBER SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY THREE THIRTY WITH
A MINUTES BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CALDERON THIS CALL THE RUN ON
THE MINUTES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AMENDMENTS TO A. B.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY AUTHORIZED
THE INCREASE TO AN BUDGET
SHORTFALLS FOR THE BOARDS OF
ACUPUNCTURE BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES
PODI AFTER TEN AND DRESSED
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF
THE STATE PRESCRIPTION DRUG
BUSINESSES SECURE. BACK LAST.
THANK YOU MISTER SEEN THIS
DEBATE ON THE MANSON WITHOUT.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE FOR ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS UP TO PRINT ABOUT ON FILE.
AND MR HANGS KIND OF EVENTS
THIS IS AB. THIRTY TWO THIRTY
FOUR. FOR THE PURPOSE OF A
MADMAN CORPORAL WITHIN THEM
SYMBOL FOR TO THE FOUR WITH BY
REMEMBER. THIS TAKE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER A PER. MEMBERS TO SB
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOUR TODAY
WILL PUT. FOR THE PURPOSE. OF
THE PA SAFETY TRAIL BILL RIVER
MORE FINAL VEHICLE SB ONE
EIGHTEEN. THAT WE ALREADY TOOK
UP EARLIER TODAY. SB THIRTY TO
THIRTY FOURTH MAN WILL HELP
IMPLEMENT IMPORTANT COST
SAVINGS. IN OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
BUDGET OUR RESPECT FOR YOUR- OR
IT BE THIRTY TWO FOUR TO BE
AMENDED OING OUT TO PRINT BACK
OFF ON. THANK YOU MISTER CHANG
MISTER ARE YOU. SEEKING RECORD.
ON THE MEMBERS. IN THE RED
MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK TO. IS THE- THE ABSURDITY
IN THE PROBLEMS BUT THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IS THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. YEAH. MR
LACKEY IF YOUR REMARKS ARE IN
REFERENCE TO THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE BEFORE THE BODY IT IS
GERMANE INAPPROPRIATE. I
BELIEVE IT DOES DO THAT. YOUR
MAIL RECEIVED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU KNOW COLLEAGUES I
BELIEVE AND I ACTUALLY HAVE A
GREAT APPRECIATION FOR THE
FORGIVE AND FORGET. PERSPECTIVE
WITH THIS ONE WAS ON CERTAIN
FRONTS BUT WHEN IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE AS WE FORGET
VICTIMS. AND THIS BILL. HAS
ZERO OFFENSE EXCLUSIONS. THAT
MEANS A PERSON WHO COMMITS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. A GUN
VIOLENCE OR HATE CRIME WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION. LET ME
CLARIFY WHAT THAT MEANS. THE
VERSION MEANS THE OFFENSE NEVER
OCCURRED. THE COMBAT THE ALL
THE TO COMMIT TO AND ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH ALL THE ELEMENTS FOR
DIVERSION. ALSO A LEGIBLE FOR
DIVERSION UNDER THIS BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS. ARE DRIVING UNDER
THE INFLUENCE FENCES. WHAT THAT
MEANS IS. WHEN IT HAS THE
POTENTIALTO ME. IS THAT
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE. IS
A VERY SERIOUS OFFENSES YOU
KNOW MY COMMITMENT TO THAT
ISSUE. WHAT IT MAY MEAN AS A NO
ONE MAY EVER BE CONVICTED OF A
FELONY OFFENSE BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T CONTINUE TO ACCUMULATE.
CONNECTIONS. JUST LAST WEEK WE
HEARD THE GOOD NEWS IS YOU SEE
ARE ANNOUNCED THAT THE PRISON
POPULATION IS BELOW A HUNDRED
THOUSAND. THE LAST TIME CDC
OURS NUMBERS WERE THAT LOW WAS
IN NINETEEN NINETY. WHEN OUR
POPULATION WAS ALMOST TEN
MILLION LESS THAN IT IS TODAY.
THIS BILL. WILL ACTUALLY
JEOPARDIZED PUBLIC SAFETY AND I
ASK THAT YOU OPPOSE EVEN AT
THIS STAGE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE BEING CONSIDERED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY. MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
JUST WANT TO REMIND MEMBERS
THAT THIS IS NOT A VOTE ON THE
BILL IS A PRE PROCEDURE OF A
SOME MOTIONS IS NOT A VOTE ON
THE BILL. MR FLORA FOR
PURPOSES. WE WITHHOLD UNANIMOUS
CONSENT NATURAL CALL VOTE ON
THESE AMENDMENTS. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THESE
AMENDMENTS. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THESE AMENDMENTS THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRED ABOUT. REQUIRES A
MAJORITY OF THOSE PRESENT AND
VOTING ON THE AMENDMENT. YEAH
BUT WHAT. IS A ROLL CALL VOTE
ON THE AMENDMENTS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS HAD WISHED ABOUT THIS
IS A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE
AMENDMENTS. TO AB. THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR. CLARK WELL. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS FOURTEEN THE
AMENDMENTS. OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS WITH CLOSE THE ROLE ON
A- THE PREVIOUS VOTE WE'RE
GOING TO. PULL THAT UP ON THE
SCREEN.
THANK YOU DAVID FOR
TWELVE CULTURAL AND TIED ABOUT
AYE AYES THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
FOURTEEN THE AMENDMENTS ARE
ADOPTED MAJORITY PRESENT AND
VOTING IS THE THRESHOLD. THE
MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED BILLS OUT
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON. AND NOW
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT TWO I
AM REFERRING THE FOLLOWING
BILLS AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
CALDERON TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE AND AB
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR BY MR
TANG TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
COMMITTEE. MY APOLOGIES.
MCGUIRE. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE
IS REMOVED TO VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IS A MEMBER
WISH TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT TO
OUR HOUSE RESOLUTION NINETY SIX
BY SUMMER BOERNER HORVATH
RELATIVE TO THE FOURTH OF JULY.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS. THERE.
OKAY. OKAY. ALL THIRTY WHICH TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CAN CALENDAR.
OUR MEMBERS VOTERS ADAM.
CARPOOL CLOSER ALL TALLY THE
VOTE I AYES FOUR KNOWS. THE CAN
SECOND OR THE TOP PARKER READ
THE REMAINING OUT OF SOCKET SO
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHT FOUR FIVE
FOUR NO. ZERO YEAH. AIR MISTER
YOU ARE FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I MOVE TO SUSPEND GENERAL SIXTY
TWO WAY THE FONG NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
THIRTY TO THIRTY FOURTEEN AT
THE HEARING ON WEDNESDAY AUGUST
FIFTH TWO HE'S MISTER FLORA
LAST TIME I PROMISED EMAILS
AGAINST RESPECT LAST CALL VOTE
THIS FLORA AS WITH ALL MISTER
CALDERON MOVES MISTER. AGAINST
OTHER DISPATCHER MEMBERS. OVER
CARPOOL. CALDERON IS ASKING FOR
A HIGH VOTE MISTER FLORA AND NO
MR CALL IS A FOR AN I. VOTE. MR
FLORA NOW MEMBERS IS PER. THIS
IS PROCEDURAL. YEAH WE. NOW WE
MAKE. CLARK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
CALVET EYES FORTY KNOWS FOR
MOTION CARRY.
RESTRAINT.
MEMBERS IN THE ABSENCE
OBJECTION WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE GRANTED
HER PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AN
INTERNET MEMORY. MR CHOI YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
IN MEMORY. THANK YOU A SPEAKER
AND THE MEMBERS. I HUMBLY ASK
THAT WE ARE DOING OUR TODAY'S
SO SOMEBODY'S SESSION IN MEMORY
OF ALL MY MOTHER. ONE AIMED
TOWARD WHO PASSED AWAY ON JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND. THE FIRST DAY OF
ALL WAS ARE. SHE WAS A KIND OF
WAY FOR TO COME. FOR MICE MORE
RECESS. ON MY WAY HOME I'VE IS
IT TO HER ON JUNE EIGHTEENTH
AFTERNOON. AND SHE PASSED AWAY.
ON THAT NIGHT. ONE IN CHORE YOU
WAS BORN TO A HOMES FAMILY ON
FEBRUARY SEVENTH. NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR IN LUNAR CALENDAR
IN NIGEL SOUTH KOREA. SHE WAS A
MOSTLY ALL HOME SCHOOLED BY HER
FATHER AFTER A FEW YES OF A
SHOW TRIAL AT A LOCAL PRIMARY
SCHOOL. SHE TO HER ALONE DEEP
INTO A CLASSIC BY HER SCOTT
FATHER. SHE GOT THE MARRIED
WITH MY FATHER IN NINETEEN
FORTY ONE AND THE MOSTLY WORKED
AS A HOMEMAKER TAKEN CARE OFF
ALL HER EIGHT CHILDREN. HUSBAND
AND ALL MONDAY AND ALL LIVING
OR- IN THE SAME HOW FOR. AS
MOST KOREAN FAMILIES DID AT
THAT TIME IN A FARMING VILLAGE.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR FOUR
SHE IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED
STATES WITH MY FATHER AND THE
LIVE MOSTLY IN CARTON GOAL FOR
UNTIL SHE BRIEFLY LIVED. IN A
NURSING HOME IN BUENA PARK. AND
IN A LOT WHEN I HEAR ALSO FOR A
MONTH AT MY BROTHER'S HALLS SO
UNTIL HER DEATH. THE GREATEST A
GIFT THAT SHE- FOR IMMIGRATING
TO THE UNITED STATES SO WAS TO
HER MEETING WITH THE JESUS
CHRIST AND THOUGH SHE WAS A
BAPTIZED SO IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. AND THE GRADUATED- FROM
BATH OR SENIOR COLLEGE IN TWO
THOUSAND. NINE IN NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN MY MOTHER WAS SO
ANNOYING TO THE TO THE TITLE OF
ALL- OF THE ECONOMY IS. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN SHE RECEIVED
CALL ON OVER TO FOR BEING A
DISTINGUISHED APPARENT. FOR
RAISING HER CHILDREN UP TO THE
LAW NOTABLE PROFESSIONALS.
DESPITE THE ADVERSE OF
CONDITIONS SO THAT THEY WERE
BORN INTO IN OUR SLEEPY FARMING
VILLAGE. MY MOTHER WAS ARE IN
LIGHTENED AND HER VERY EARLY
AGE FOR THE VALUE OF EDUCATION
AND A SHE WAS SO DETERMINED NOT
TO EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN AS FAR
AS SAW THEIR ABILITIES SO WOULD
REACH SURE REPEATEDLY. TOLD US
THAT TO. I DON'T PLAN TO
INHERIT THE MY PROPERTY TO YOU.
ARE THE RATHER SELMA SELDOM AS
YOU BECAUSE NO ONE CAN STEAL
YOUR KNOWLEDGE OF YOUR BRAIN
LARA'S SAW YOU MAY LOSE YOUR
INHERIT THE PROPERTY IS WAS
MODEL ONES. SHE SANG A SONG TO
ALSO THE TIME TO LIST HARM.
THAT THE CONTAINED LYRICS
SAYING. PHONE DOCTOR YOU WOULD
A PER OF TO. THE TIME WHEN FLOW
AWAY LIKE GO FOR WATER. IF YOU
DON'T STUDY. WHILE YOU ARE
YOUNG THE ARSENAL YOU'LL SO
EVEN IF FOR YOUR REQUIRE OUT
UPON YOUR GRAY HAIR. AND THE
RESULT THE PRODUCE. LIKE ME A
PROFESSOR A DOCTOR A NURSE A
TEACHER. AND THE BUSINESSMAN
SHE WAS A GREAT EDUCATOR. MY
MOTHER IS FULLY PASSED AWAY ON
JUNE NINETEENTH AND WENT TO
HEAVEN TO JOIN WITH THE JESUS
CHRIST. I ASK THAT BUT WE ARE
JOINED TODAY'S SESSION IN
MEMORY OF MY MOTTO WHEN IN
CHORE THANK YOU THANK YOU
DOCTOR CHOI ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE BODY MY CONDOLENCES.
DOCTOR WEBER. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY IN THE REAR CHAMBER I'M
GOING TO ALLOW MY COLLEAGUE WHO
HAS A MEETING WITH THE
GOVERNOR- TO GO FIRST OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON MR DOLLARS YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE GERMAN MEMORY
THANK YOU AND THIS WAS IN AN
ATTEMPT TO NOT HAVE TO GO AFTER
DOCTOR WEBER. ALTHOUGH I MIGHT
USE IN THE FUTURE. MEMBERS
TODAY MY GREAT HONOR AND
SADNESS TO RISE IS THE CHAIR
LATINO LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO
ASK THAT WE TURN IN MEMORY OF
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER CONGRESSMAN
JOHN LEWIS. OUR PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS WATCHED AS HE WAS
BEATEN AND THELMA. AND HE
BECAME THE CONSCIOUSNESS OF THE
ENTIRE NATION. AND YET DECADES
HAVE PASSED IN OUR BLACK BLACK
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ARE STILL
FIGHTING FOR THE RACIAL JUSTICE
THE HE BEGAN FIVE FOR. AND WE
IN THE LATINO COMMUNITY
UNDERSTAND THAT FIGHT WE FIGHT.
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER. AND WE
CAN RELY ON JOHN LEWIS TO FIGHT
OUR FIGHT AS WELL HE WAS AN
ALLY TO LATINOS THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE CAREER INCLUDING A ON
WAVERING SUPPORT FOR IMMIGRANTS
AND THOSE WHO LOOK TO THE
UNITED STATES AS A HUGE FOR NEW
BEGINNINGS. HE FIERCELY
FAMILIES BRACED THE US BORDER.
NOT BE P. IN AMERICA UNTIL
YOUNG RE TO THE- IT DOESN'T
MATTER. WHETHER WE ARE BLACK OR
WHITE LATINO ASIAN AMERICAN OR
NATIVE AMERICAN NOW IS THE TIME
TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT HE SAID WHAT
IS FAIR AND WHAT IS JUST. HE
ORDER DREAM. WE NEED TO SUPPORT
AND TWENTY WITH A DEAL TO
PROTECT DOCTOR STATING WE MUST
NOT GIVE UP GIVE IN. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO PRESS ON. HE WAS
THERE FOR US EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. ANY RECOGNIZE THAT ANY. IF
ANY RADICAL SOCIAL POLITICAL
AND ECONOMIC CHANGES WHICH TAKE
PLACE IN OUR SOCIETY THE PEOPLE
THE MASSES MUST BRING THEM
ABOUT. AS MEMBERS OF
LEGISLATIVE BODY WE CAN'T
UNDERSTATE THE SACRIFICES THAT
JOHN LEWIS MADE FOR ALL OF US
HIS COURAGE AND DETERMINATION.
DEMONSTRATED THROUGHOUT HIS
LIFE AND THROUGHOUT. HIS
ACTIONS. DURING THESE TIMES OF
JUSTIFIED CIVIL UNREST WE NEED
THAT KIND OF HEROISM WE NEED TO
SHINE LIGHT ON THE HARSH
REALITIES OF THE SYSTEM WAS
BUILT TO BENEFIT SOME AND NOT
ALL. AND WE NEED TO SHINE
LIGHT. ON A GREATEST HERO WHO
CONTINUE TO SHINE HIS LIGHT ON
ALL OF US. WE MUST STAND AND
FIGHT AGAINST RACISM AND
CLASSISM AND BIGOTRY AS JOHN
LEWIS ASKED US TO DO ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT'S COMING FROM THE
LEVELS OF OUR OF OUR OFFICE.
AND WE MUST SUPPORT INTRODUCED
POLICIES THAT HELP TO BREAK
DOWN THE BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
OUR BLACK BROTHERS AND SISTERS
OUR WORKERS ARE IMMIGRANTS ALL
OF OUR AGENTS IN ADDRESSING
DIGNIFY LOT. THAT'S WHAT THIS
MAN STOOD FOR. IT WAS THROUGH
HIS ACTIONS WE LEARNED. MY
ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO. CELLS
IT'S THROUGH ACTIVE. BROUGHT ON
TO. AND HER PARENTS STORIES
THAT WE WERE TAUGHT. BUT THERE
IS NO FEAR IN STANDING UP FOR
YOURSELF. AND SO. WE HOPE THAT
WE CAN HELP CARRY ON. THIS CALL
MEN'S COME TO BUILD A COUNTRY
THAT TREATS US ALL WITH EACH.
WITH EQUITY AND WITH DIGNITY.
HIS DEATH CAN'T BE IN VAIN. AND
WE RISE SHOULDER SHOULDER WITH
A BLACK CAUCUS TO RESPECT THE
LIFE A CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES DOCTOR
WEBER I WILL NOT RECOGNIZE YOU
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AKA
MANAH SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D RUN
ON BEHALF OF THE CAL
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND MY
COLLEAGUE WILL LEAVE IN FREE
RIDES ON BEHALF OF THE CAUCUS
FOR MISTER VIVIAN TO INTO. WHO
EMPOWER ALL OF OUR LIVE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD.
JOHN LEWIS WAS BORN IN NINETEEN
FORTY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY FIRST
IN A LITTLE TOWN CALLED FULLY.
ALABAMA AND HE WAS KNOWN AS A
BOY FROM TROY. HE LIVED HIS
LIFE IN THE DEATHS OF RACISM
AND A PORTS SEGREGATION EVEN
WITH THE NINETEEN FIFTY FOUR
BOARD OF EDUCATION I BROUGHT.
BROWN VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION
NEVER REACHED HIS GOAL AND
DIRECTLY IMPACTED LIVE. THAT'S
ONE OF THE KINGS INSPIRED HIM.
AND THE SPORTS IN IN THE END
THAT WAS THERE FOR HIM IN
NINETEEN SEVEN WHEN HE LEFT
ALABAMA. FOR TENNESSEE AND
LEARN OF THE NON BY THE
PROTESTS. A TWO. USED THE- IT
WAS NO IT TORY HIS WOULD MAKE
THE NINETY THREE WE SEE HIM ON
THE MARTIN. AS A YOUNG SPEAKER
ON THAT ON THAT. WE ALL SAW HIM
AND TERMS WHAT HAVE WITH THE-
NINE SIXTY FIVE WITH. AND THE
BRIDGE AND THE THAT WAS THERE
AND WE SAW A LITTLE BEING BE.
AND TAKE AWAY. HE NEVER STOPPED.
NUMBER ONE. I MEAN I KIND OF
THE CALL. MY COLLEAGUES THE
PROBABLY GOING TALK TO YOU MORE
SPECIFIC AND ABOUT THE LEWIS.
BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT. WHAT
WILL LIKE TO BE A WOO. IN THIS
COUNTRY. YOU KNOW I'M A
DAUGHTER OF SHARE CRY. AND SO I
WHAT IT MEANS HAVE A FAMILY
THAT IS A SHE FAMILY. I KNOW
THE IN SECURE. THAT EXIST IN
YOUR LIFE. I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
JUST A HALF STEP SLOW. BUT
MAYBE OFF BECAUSE IN THE ON
THIS SOMEONE TOOK YOUR LIFE HAD
TO LEAVE PAY THE PER WHO OWNS
IT. WORK WORK KIND OF CAUTIOUS
ABOUT TAKING UPPEOPLE'S PER.
WHAT'S IS NOT THE CASE IF YOU
WERE SHOULD ACROSS. KIND JOHN
LEWIS NOT ONLY. TIM'S WITH WITH
THE WE THINK OF THE- BUT TO
READ THE STORY LIFE. AND YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT FAMILY WAS ALSO
IN. AND COSTLY BE THREATENED. I
SO THEREFORE THEY DIDN'T HIM TO
GO FAR AND OF RAY THAT YOU.
BECAUSE IF HE HAD DONE THAT.
THEY COULD HAVE TO HIS MOTHER
HIS FATHER. THEY COULD BURN
DOWN HOUSE. WE COULD KILL HIM.
AND THERE WOULD BE NO JUSTICE
IN ANY OF THAT FOR HIM. THAT'S
THE LIFE OF A SHARECROPPER
THAT'S THE LIFE OF LIVING IN A
SOCIETY THAT YOU DON'T LOVE.
AND YET JOHN LEWIS LOVE TO THIS
COUNTRY MORE THAN THEY EVER
LOVED. ANY CAP ON TO VERY END
OF ALL US WHO ARE HERE. AND SO
WHEN YOU THINK OF HIM YOU KNOW
THE JUST CAN'T. DO HE WAS
SHARECROPPER SURE. IS THE-
FAMILY WAS IN. AND THAT IN KNEW
CLEAR THAT IF HAD DONE ANYTHING
HIM. OR HER FAMILY OR BURN. OR
TAKEN A PROPERTY SOME ME. SOME
ILLEGAL MEANS I SAY. THAT WOULD
BE NOT HE COULD DO TO BACK. AND
WOULD PROBABLY NOT HAVE EVER
HEARD OF NAME JOE LEWIS. IF
THEY HAD DONE THOSE THE TO HIM.
WHAT'S NUMBER THE- OF GOD. HE
WAS ABLE TO LOOK. AND TO. SIX
YEARS JOHN WAS A SOMEONE WE
SHOULD LOOK UP TO BE WE READ
THAT HE WAS I AT A TIME UNLIKE
TODAY YOUNG PEOPLE CAN IN THE
STREETS AND THEY AND THEY THEIR
LAW ON THE LINE. BUT WE
UNDERSTAND THE DEPTH OF FEAR
AND THE DEPTH OF HER CAR LIVED
IN. ITSELF WHY DOES IN A MATTER
SEC AND HE KNEW THAT HE WAS
JUST BALL I DON'T SELL WHEN HE
SAW HIM A TWO BEING KILLED AND
SEEING THE TRIAL OF AND YOU'LL
AND THOSE BEING A IT AND THEN
COME OUT AND SELLING STORE TO
MEGA FOR TO DOLLARS OF HOW THEY
AND TORTURED HIM IN. HE WAS
ONLY YEAR OLDER THE IMAGE. SO
HE KNEW THE PAIR I THINK FACED
A DAY. ACTION AND WHEN YOU MEET
HIM YOU WOULD FIND A PERSON SO
HUMBLE HE WOULD NEVER MENTIONED
HIS NAME. HE WOULD NEVER TELL
YOU WHAT HE HAD DONE. HE NEVER
TOOK CREDIT FOR THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN FIFTY
SIXTY FIVE. HE NOW TOOK CREDIT
FOR WHAT HAPPENED IN THE SOUTH.
BECAUSE HE SAW HIMSELF JUST AS
THE- END. WHO PART OF THEM. I
HE HAD KNOWS. DEAL OTHER THAN
HIS THE TERMINATION TO FIGHT
FOR HIS FREEDOM. AND THE
FREEDOM OF OTHERS. WE STAND ON
A GIANT TODAY. AND AS YOU HEAR
THE STORY OF HIS LIFE NEVER
FORGET. THAT HE CAME FROM SOME
OF THE WORST CIRCUMSTANCES YOU
COULD. IMAGINE IF YOU DID NOT
LIVE IN THE SOUTH AND YOU DID
NOT UNDERSTAND YOUR PROPERTY.
THE MOST THE ONLY PEOPLE IN THE
FACE OF THE- MY FATHER FLED
HOPE ARKANSAS BECAUSE HE STOOD
UP. HE STOOD UP AND THEY WERE
GOING TO MENTION. MY WHOLE
FAMILY MOVED AND THE REST OF
THE FAMILY WITH THE CONSTANT.
BECAUSE WE LIVE THE LIFE THAT
WAS SO FRIENDLY. BUT THEY COULD
TAKE IT. THERE WOULD NEVER BE A
RECORD. THAT WOULD NEVER BE
ANYONE PERSECUTED. EVEN IF
THERE WAS A PICTURE OF YOU AS
THEY ARE IN MANY CASES OF
LYNCHING. STANDING IN FRONT OF
THE- BACK TO JUST LAST. YOU
WOULD NOT BE TRIED CONVICTED
FOR ANY CRIME WHATSOEVER. THE
DAY THE DOOR. INTERMENT ALL IN
A PRE FOR JOHN WILL WHO HAS
BEEN IN IN MY LIFE WHEN I PASS
AB NINE FIVE AND I WAS ASKED TO
WATER THE BILL DOWN I THOUGHT
ABOUT IT I PRAYED ABOUT IT AND
THAT NIGHT WHAT I SAW WAS JOHN
LEWIS ON PRESS BRIDGE. THE
MOVIE SO MUCH JUST BEEN
RELEASED AND I REALIZE WHAT I
WAS DOING SMALL IN COMPARISON
JOHN HAD DONE MY LIFE WAS NOT
IN MARK THIS IS THE STILL BE
THERE YES I MAY NOT GET ELECTED
YET. OFFICE OF LINE. IN THE END
I HAD RIGHTS STAY AND TO FIGHT
BECAUSE IT WILL A LITTLE MAY
FROM TO THE BOY FROM SURE IF
THE FOR ALL OF US IN TIME LIFE.
ACTUALLY ASKED YOU JOIN IN
MEMORY OF RON LEWIS. AND THEN
COMMIT US TO SOME GOOD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER.
MISTER GORE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE FRONT OF THE CHAMBER ON
THIS IN TO MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. MEMBERS I RISE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE LGBT CAUCUS. IN
MEMORY OF REPRESENTATIVE JOHN
LEWIS. REPRESENTED LEWIS WAS A
START AND EARLY DEFENDER OF THE
RIGHTS OF THE L. G. B. T.
COMMUNITY. NINETEEN NINETY IS
FAMOUSLY DELIVERED AN
IMPASSIONED SPEECH AGAINST THE
DEFENSE OF MARRIAGE ACT ON THE
FLOOR THE UNITED STATES HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES. HE DID THIS
AT A TIME WHEN IT WAS NOT
POPULAR DE. HE STILL DIDN'T.
AND AS IS ONE OF MANY MANY
EXAMPLES OF HIS LIFE WHEN HE
DID THAT VERY THING. MEMBERS
THE RIDE HE SAID YOU WANT THAT
I HAVE HEARD THE REASONS FOR
OPPOSING CIVIL MARRIAGE FOR
SAME SEX COUPLES. CUT TO THE
DISPATCH MEANS AND THE STINK OF
THE SAME FEAR HATRED AND
TOLERANCE I HAVE KNOWN IN
RACISM AND BIGOTRY. ARAFAT TO
HARD AND FOUGHT TO LONG AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON RACE
AND COLOR NOT TO STAND UP
AGAINST DISCRIMINATION BASED ON
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS UTILIZE HIS POWER AS A
LEGISLATOR TO MOVE THE NATIONAL
AGENDA AND COSPONSORED MANY
PLAYING BILL THROUGHOUT HIS
CAREER LONGER ITS POPULAR TO
PROTECT IN ADVANCE. OKAY
AMERICANS. HE RECOGNIZES SO
MANY OF US ON THIS FLOOR DE
THAT EACH OF OUR STRUGGLES OUR
INTER CONNECTED AND THE ACT IN
TO MITIGATE ON BEHALF OF THE
INJUSTICES THAT HE SAW. IT WAS
WE ALL WHAT THIS PAST WEEK WHEN
WE SAW THE FUNERAL PROCESSION
REALLY ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT
THE ONE IN ATLANTA THIS STOCK
IN THE HISTORIC HEART OF THE
CLEAR COMMUNITY IN. GEORGIA
THAT WAS A TESTAMENT TO THE
CONNECTION THE CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS HAD WITH THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY IN FACT I QUOTE THE
LATTER CITY COUNCIL PRESIDENT
HE ONCE SAID. WE COULD ALWAYS
COUNT ON HIM TO BE THERE
WITHOUT HAVING TO ASK. GOT THE
PRESIDENT. WILLARD THE FIRST
OPENLY GAY PERSON ELECTED IN
SANTA SHE SAID HE SAID THE
THINGS THAT NEEDED FEET SAID AT
A TIME WHEN I WANTED TO SEE
THEM. HE SAID IT WITH A COME. A
LOCAL. PEOPLE LISTEN. EVEN IF
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO. ON BEHALF
OF OUR CAUCUS TODAY NUMBERS I
RISE TO SAY THANK YOU
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS THANK
YOU FOR BEING A FRIEND TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND FOR BREAKING
DOWN BARRIERS BETWEEN OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY'RE STILL TOO
OFTEN THERE I THINK ABOUT THE
POWER OF EXAMPLE THE CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT ON SPEAKING OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE LGBTQ FOLKS AND
THE MESSAGE THAT SENSE TO OUR
COMMUNITY ITS ENTIRETY BUT
PARTICULARLY TO BLACK MEMBERS
OF THE COMMUNITY WHO NEED TO
HAVE MORE CHAMPION SAY THAT ARE
CAN THESE DESERVED AND MUST
STAND. FOR ONE ANOTHER AND SO I
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE UNDERSTAND WE
ARE FRIENDS WE THANK JOHN LEWIS
FOR HIS FRIENDS. FROM HIS
RECOGNITION IN THE FIRST. THERE
WELL THE CONTINUE TO GET INTO
IN THE YEARS AHEAD OF UP TO
BEING EXAMPLE THE CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS LEFT THE SAW. SO WE SAY
TO JOHN LEWIS MAY YOU REST IN
PEACE GOOD MAN. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GOOD TROUBLE. WE'LL TAKE
IT FROM HERE THANK YOU TO OUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AGAIN
AS THE SUN WAS DANTE THIS
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA MISTER DAVID CHIU YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THIS IS YOUR
<c.magenta>EMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER</c>
AS CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA API
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ADJOURNED I
JOIN IN THE ADJOURNMENT OF THE
MEMORY OF AN INCREDIBLE ICON.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS. THE
LEADERSHIP OF ALL OF OUR
DIVERSE CAUCUSES ARE JOINING
OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SPEAKING UP TODAY.
BECAUSE WE WOULD NOT BE HERE
WITHOUT HIS FIGHT WITHOUT THE
ADVANCES THAT HE MADE WITHOUT
HIS EXAMPLE. HIS QUEST FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS HE WAS BEATEN AND
ATTACKED BY WHITE SUPREMACISTS
AND THE POLICE. HE LED PROTESTS
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH AT LUNCH
COUNTERS ON BUSES AND AT
COURTHOUSES. AS A STUDENT
NONVIOLENCE DESPITE BEING MET
WITH VIOLENCE HE PERSISTED AND
IS PEACEFUL PURSUIT FOR JUSTICE
AND THE RIGHT TO VOTE. AND THE
QUESTION WE ASKED OURSELVES TO
A WOULD WE HAVE DONE WHAT HE
DID. HIS EFFORTS CULMINATED IN
SO MUCH IN THE PASSAGE OF THE
LANDMARK CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR. THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. AND I WILL SAY. PASSAGE
OF THE IMMIGRATION AND
NATURALIZATION ACT WHICH
REMOVED THE DISCRIMINATORY
QUOTA SYSTEM THAT PREVENTED SO
MANY ASIAN AMERICANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS FROM
IMMIGRATING TO THE UNITED
STATES. THERE ARE SO MANY
MOMENTS. IN WHICH HIS ADVOCACY
MATTER TO OUR COMMUNITY. MARINE
SO PROUD WHEN THE FIRST ASIAN
AMERICAN ONE HIS CONFIRMATION
TO BE THE ASSISTANT ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOR CIVIL RIGHTS BILL
LAN LEE UNDER THE CLINTON
MINISTRATION. AND WHO WAS THERE
PUSHING FOR THIS ONE
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS. HE
CONTINUED TO BE A STALWART
CHAMPION FOR CIVIL RIGHTS AND
TELLS PASSAGE AND I JOIN OUR
COLLEAGUES IN ASKING THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY TODAY.
AND THAT WE REDEDICATE
OURSELVES TO HONOR HIS LEGACY
OF FREEDOM EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
AND TO CONTINUE TO FIGHT FOR
GOOD TROUBLE. REST IN POWER
CONGRESSMAN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FOR GABRIEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF JEWISH CAUCUS TO REQUEST
THAT WE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS. A WELL
KNOWN JEWISH PROPER TEACHERS
THE WHOLE WORLD IS A VERY
NARROW BRIDGE AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS NOT TO BE
AFRAID. OVER THE COURSE OF HIS
REMARKABLE LIFE JOHN LEWIS TO
CROSS BRIDGES BUILT BRIDGES AND
ABOVE ALL CHANGE THE COURSE OF
HISTORY WITH UTTER FEARLESSNESS.
BORN THE SON OF SHARECROPPERS
JOHNLEWIS ASCENDED FROM HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS TO BECOME A HERO IN
THE STRUGGLE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS
AND SOCIAL JUSTICE INSPIRATION
TO AMERICA OF ALL BACKGROUNDS
AND A MORAL COMPASS FOR OUR
NATION. AMONG HIS MANY TRIBUTES
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS WAS RENOWNED
FOR HIS UNSHAKABLE
DETERMINATION AND FEARLESSNESS
IN THE PURSUIT OF JUSTICE. AND
HIS WILLINGNESS TO MENTOR GREAT
PERSONAL SACRIFICE IN SERVICE
WHAT HE PROBABLY CALLED GOOD
TROUBLE. ARRESTED MORE THAN
FOUR TIMES DURING THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENTS AND NUMEROUS
TIMES THERE AFTER INCLUDING AS
A MEMBER OF CONGRESS
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS WAS
REPEATEDLY ATTACKED VICIOUSLY
BEAT. OFTEN BY POLICE YEAH HE
NEVER HESITATED TO CONTINUE HIS
ACTIVISM. NEARLY FIFTY YEARS
OLD IN AWARDING HIM THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM
PRESIDENT OBAMA OBSERVED
GENERATIONS FOR NOW. PARENTS
TEACH THEIR CHILDREN WHAT IS
MEANT BY COURAGE THE STORY OF
JOHN LEWIS WILL COME TO MIND.
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY JOHN LEWIS
WAS MORE THAN AN INSPIRATION HE
WAS OUR FRIEND OUR PARTNER OUR
CHAMPION IN THE STAUNCHEST
ALLIES FOR MORE THAN HALF A
CENTURY. IN HIS AUTOBIOGRAPHY
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS REFLECTED
ABOUT THE KINSHIP HE FELT
TOWARDS THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
FOR DURING A CHILD OR HE
WITNESSED WHITE SUB KNOWS THE
WORD GEO WITH CONTEMPT. QUOTE
SPITTING IT OUT LIKE A BAD
PIECE OF FOOD. OVER THE COURSE
OF HIS LIFETIME CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS A FIRM THAT CAN SHIP
THROUGH WORD AND DEED. HE SPOKE
OUT POWERFULLY AGAINST ANTI%
SEMITISM MARCHED IN SUPPORT OF
SOVIET JEWRY FOUNDED THE
ATLANTA BLACK JEWISH COALITION
WAS A PROMINENT AND VOCAL
SUPPORTER OF ISRAEL IN THE US
IS RELATIONSHIP. AND IN THE
LAST YEAR OF HIS LIFE WAS A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL CAUCUS ON BLACK
JEWISH RELATIONS. ON A PERSONAL
LEVEL CONGRESSMAN LEWIS WAS
ALSO A BELOVED MENTOR AND
FRIEND TO MANY JEWISH LEADERS
AND POLITICAL ACTIVISTS.
INCLUDING A PACK NATIONAL
POLITICAL DIRECTOR OUR BASS AND
THE SERVICE IS CHIEF OF STAFF
IN THE US HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES. FOR MANY IN
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY JOHN LEWIS
WAS THE LIVING EMBODIMENT OF
THE QUEST FOR JUSTICE LOVING
KINDNESS IN HUMAN DIGNITY THAT
ARE THE HIGHEST CALLING OF
JEWISH TRADITION. AS WE MORE
CONGRESSMAN LEWIS IT FEELS
ESPECIALLY PAINFUL THAT WE
WOULD LOSE HIM DURING A MOMENT
OF PROFOUND NATIONAL
UNCERTAINTY AND DOUBT. AS OUR
NATION WRESTLES WITH A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC DEVASTATING RECESSION
AND THE ON RENT UNRELENTING
BURDEN OF DEADLY SYSTEMIC
RACISM. AND YET IN THIS MOMENT
IT SEEMS ESPECIALLY FITTING TO
RECALL HIS POWERFUL EXAMPLE OF
COURAGE AND FEARLESSNESS IN THE
FACE OF SEEMINGLY
INSURMOUNTABLE OBSTACLES. DO
NOT GET LOST IN A SEA OF
DESPAIR HE WROTE IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BE HOPEFUL BE
OPTIMISTIC. OUR STRUGGLE IS NOT
THE STRUGGLE OF A DAY A WEEK A
MONTH OR A YEAR IT IS THE
STRUGGLE OF A LIFETIME NEVER
EVER BE AFRAID TO MAKE SOME
NOISE IN GETTING GOOD TROUBLE
NECESSARY TROUBLE. PERHAPS MORE
THAN ANY AMERICAN OF HIS
GENERATION JOHN LEWIS SHOWED US
WHAT REVENUE OFTEN TIME. THAT
IF WE CAN SUMMON THE COURAGE TO
CROSS THE NARROW BRIDGE WITHOUT
FEAR. WE CAN CHANGE THE WORLD.
MAY THE MEMORY OF JOHN LEWIS BE
A BLESSING. ON BEHALF OF THE
JEWISH CAUCUS AND ITS
SOLIDARITY WITH THE COULD THE
BLACK CAUCUS AND OUR SISTER
CAUCUSES. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN TODAY
IN HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU MR
GABRIEL MISS CAMARGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. MADAM SPEAKER. GOOD
AFTERNOON TODAY I RISE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
AMERICAN POLITICIAN AND CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER AND LEGEND
CONGRESSMAN JOHN ROBERT LOUIS
WHO PASSED AWAY ON FRIDAY JULY
SEVENTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AFTER
A SIX MONTH BATTLE WITH
PANCREATIC CANCER. CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS WAS AN ICON HE WAS A BIG
SIX LEADER. OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT OF THE NINETEEN
NINETIES. HE WAS A TWO THOUSAND
AND ELEVEN RECIPIENT. OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF FREEDOM.
HE WAS A PROUD MEMBER. OF FIVE
BETA SIGMA A SIBLING PATERNAL
ORGANIZATION OF MY OWN. HE WAS
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR WOMEN. HE
FOUGHT IN POVERTY FOR CHILDREN
BY CO SPONSORING THE PAYCHECK
FAIRNESS ACT TO ELIMINATE PAY
DISPARITIES BETWEEN MEN AND
WOMEN. CO SPONSORING THE
HEALTHY FAMILIES ACT
STANDARDIZING PAID SICK DAYS.
CO SPONSORING THE FAMILY
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT WHICH WOULD
EXPAND BENEFITS. AND CLOSE
SPONSORING THE VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN REAUTHORIZATION ACT. AS
WELL AS MARCHING NUMEROUS TIMES
WITH. AND FOR WOMEN AND WOMEN'S
RIGHTS. YOU KNOW TRUE TO HIS
PURPOSE. IN HIS FINAL OP ED
WHICH WAS PUBLISHED BY THE NEW
YORK TIMES THE DAY OF HIS
HOMECOMING CELEBRATION. HE LEFT
US A ROADMAP. REMINDING US THAT
DEMOCRACY IS AN ACT IT IS NOT A
STATE. HE TOLD US TO STAND UP.
FOR WHAT YOU BELIEVE IN. TO LAY
DOWN THE BURDENS OF THE VISION
TO DEMAND RESPECT FOR HUMAN
DIGNITY. HE WROTE THAT EMMETT
TILL WAS HIS GEORGE FLOYD.
REYES SARBUCKS BRIANNA TAYLOR.
THEY WERE HIS TAIL. FOR MANY OF
US. CONGRESS MEMBER JOHN ROBERT
LOUIS WAS OUR DR KING. THEY
BOTH SAID TO BE SILENCE IS TO
BE COMPLICIT. CONGRESS NUMBER
LUIS. WAS TRULY LIVING HISTORY.
HE WAS SOMEONE BOTH WRITTEN
ABOUT. IN THE HISTORY BOOKS.
AND WAS A LIVING MONUMENT. TO
WHAT PURSUE VARIANCE AND
PURPOSE LOOKS LIKE. FOR SO MANY
OF US FIGHTING FOR JUSTICE. HE
WAS OUR NORTH STAR. AND HE
DIDN'T DO ANY OF THIS ALONE. AS
WAS MENTIONED THE FIGHT FOR THE
VOTING RIGHTS ACT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE. IT WAS A COLLECTIVE
ACT. IT SEEMS LIKE AN
IMPOSSIBLE IN TREACHEROUS GOAL.
IT BROUGHT MURDER IN DEATH WITH
IT. AND HE DIDN'T ACHIEVE THAT
ALONE HE ACHIEVED THAT WITH SO
MANY ALLIES. ROOM ALL ME ALL
DIFFERENT KINDS OF STRIPES. ALL
FIGHTING FOR COMMON PURPOSE.
WHICH HOPEFULLY WE CAN DO AS WE
FIGHT FOR THINGS LIKE.
PROPOSITIONS SEVENTEEN AND
FIGHTING AGAINST VOTER ID LAWS
AND VOTER SUPPRESSION THAT IS
HAPPENING OUR TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY VERSION. OF POLL TAXES
AND LITERACY TAXES AND TEST TO
GET US TO THE POLLS. HIS STORY
HIS LIFE. MIRRORS THE POEM
INVICTUS. IN HIS ROLE IN THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT HIS HEAD
HAD BEEN BLOODIED. BUT WAS ALL
PAYS ON BACK OUT. HIS YEARS
WITNESSING MAKING HISTORY AND
NOW ITS MENACING REPEAT OF
HISTORY FOUND HIM UNAFRAID. HIS
JOURNEY WAS NOT STRAIGHT NOR
WITHOUT PUNISHMENT. BUT HE
REMAINED THE MASTER OF HIS FATE.
AND THE CAPTAIN OF THE SOUL OF
WHAT AMERICA CAN BE.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN ROBERT LOUIS
CENTERED OUR CONGRESS AND THIS
NATION. TO NOT ACCEPT THE WAY
THINGS ARE. BUT TO STAND UP AND
SAY SOMETHING. AND DO SOMETHING.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN ROBERT LOUIS
IS TRULY REPLACEABLE TO SO MANY
OF US. I JOIN WITH MY ALLIES
AND COLLEAGUES AS A MEMBER OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BLACK
CAUCUS THE JEWISH CAUCUS THE
API POCKETS. AND THE L. G. B.
TO CAUCUS. TWO GERMAN THE
MEMORY OF CONGRESSMAN LEWIS
THANK YOU MISS CLARK THE FROM
OTHER. MAY HIS MEMORY BE A
BLESSING OF ARE ALL OF US TO
GET INTO GOOD TROUBLE. MR
HOLDING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
THE NEXT TWO GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE. TO JOIN IN THE
MEMORY. OF CORDY TEN DEL VIVIAN.
ALSO KNOWN AS C. T. VIVIAN BORN
IN BOONVILLE MISSOURI ON JULY
THIRTIETH NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR
THE ONLY CHILD OF ROBERT AND
USE THAT A TEN DEL VIDEO. HIS
FAMILY MOVED TO MACOMB ILLINOIS
WHEN HE WAS SIX AND HE LATER
GRADUATED FROM A CALL HIGH
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO.
HE STUDIED HISTORY AT WESTERN
ILLINOIS UNIVERSITY- MACOMB BUT
HE DROPPED OUT AND BECAME A
RECREATION WORKER IN PEORIA
ILLINOIS WHERE HE JOINED HIS
FIRST PROTEST. IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN HELPING TO
DESEGREGATE A CAFETERIA. ROBIN
VIVIAN WAS A BAPTIST PREACHER
ALONG WITH JOHN LEWIS BILL
GENERAL FOR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR. AND AN ORGANIZER FOR
THE SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN
LEADERSHIP CONFERENCE. IT WAS-THE NATIONAL DIRECTOR OF
ROUGHLY EIGHTY FIVE LOCAL
AFFILIATES CHAPTERS OF THE SCLC
FROM NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. TO
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX DIRECTING
PROTEST ACTIVITIES AND TRAINING
AND NON VIOLENCE AS WELL AS
COORDINATING VOTER REGISTRATION
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
PROJECTS. HE'S BEEN DESCRIBED
AS THE DISCIPLINE ADVOCATE FOR
NONVIOLENCE EVEN WHILE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF BLOODY VIOLENT
CONFRONTATIONS. ROBIN CT VIVIAN
LIKE MANY OF HIS GENERATION
DEMONSTRATED UNPARALLELED
STRENGTH. COURAGE AND
COMMITMENT TO STEP IN THE GAP
TO ADVOCATE AND GIVE VOICE FOR
SO MANY DESPERATE FOR RACIAL
JUSTICE. OFTEN PUTTING HIS LIFE
ON THE LINE BY AND DURING
PHYSICAL. BEATINGS ARRESTS
THREATS IN DE HUMANIZING
TREATMENT. AS REPORTED IN THE
NEW YORK TIMES ON HIS PASSING.
WHO STATED HE LED PASSED THE
PROTESTERS. ANGRY WHITE MOBS
AND WITH DISCIPLINE AND
DURRANCE ABSORBED THE BLOWS OF
SEGREGATIONISTS AND COMPLICIT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
ACROSS THE SOUTH. WHO CIVIL
RIGHTS WORK CONTINUED FOR A
HALF CENTURY. HE BECAME
DIRECTOR OF THE URBAN TRAINING
CENTER FOR CHRISTIAN MISSIONS
IN CHICAGO IN NINETEEN SIXTY
SIX AND DEAN OF THE SHAW
UNIVERSITY DIVINITY SCHOOL A
RALEIGH NORTH CAROLINA IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. HE LATER
FOUNDED THE BLACK ACTION
STRATEGIES AND INFORMATION
CENTER IN ATLANTA THE FOSTER
WORKPLACE RACE RELATIONS WHO
WAS A FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL.
PLANNED NETWORK WHICH MONITORS
HATE GROUPS. IT WAS LATER
RENAMED THE CENTER FOR
DEMOCRATIC RENEWAL TO REFLECT
THE BROADER EDUCATIONAL GOALS.
RIVEN VIVIAN WAS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR CLERGY IN THE
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN OF
REVEREND JESSE JACKSON.
APPEARED HE APPEARED ON THE
EYES ON THE PRIZE IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PBS DOCUMENTARY.
ON THE CIVIL RIGHTS ERA AND WAS
LATER THE FOCUS OF A PBS
SPECIAL THE HEALING MINISTRY OF
DOCTOR CT VIVIAN. HE RECEIVED
THE PRESIDENTIAL MEDAL OF
FREEDOM. THE NATION'S HIGHEST
CIVIL CIVILIAN HONOR FROM
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. REVENUE
VIVIAN LIKE SO MANY BEFORE AND
AFTER HIMEXEMPLIFIED WHAT
SCRIPTURE REFERS TO AS LONG
SUFFERING. PATIENTLY AND DURING
LAST IN OFFENSE OR HER OR
HARDSHIP AND EXHIBITING A GREAT
DEAL OF PATIENCE WARREN
DURRANCE. OF THE MISTREATMENT
BY OTHERS. LONG SUFFERING AS WE
ALL KNOW IS THE FRUIT OF THE
HOLY SPIRIT ENABLES US TO NEVER
GIVE UP REGARDLESS OF OUR
CIRCUMSTANCES LOVE JOY. PEACE
HI MISS GOODNESS FAITHFULNESS
GENTLENESS SELF CONTROL THESE
ARE ALSO FRUITS OF THE SPIRIT.
THERE'S A SCRIPTURE DECLARES IF
WE LIVE IN THE SPIRIT WITH US
ALSO WALK IN THE SPIRIT. BERMAN
CITY VERY AS LIFE WAS AS A
CONSTANT WITNESS TO A LIFE
LIVED. AND WALKED IN THE SPIRIT.
RIVEN VIVIAN IS SURVIVED BY
DAUGHTERS CURA VIVIAN DENISE
MORSE JOANNE WALKER A NEEDED
THORTON TO ARE VIVIAN AND
ALBERT VIVIAN. NINE
GRANDCHILDREN TEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN TWENTY EIGHT
GREAT GREAT GRANDCHILDREN AND
TWO GREAT GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. ANOTHER SON
CORDY JUNIOR DIED IN TWENTY TEN.
RIVER CITY VERY HAVE FOUGHT THE
GOOD FIGHT. FINISH THE RACE IN
THE FACE. MAY HE REST IN PEACE.
THANK YOU MISTER HALL THEN. MR
MILAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY IN THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
A BELOVED FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOBBYIST AND SAN MATTEO COUNTY
RESIDENT BUILD TO **** BUT IN
SAN FRANCISCO BILL GREW UP IN
SAN CARLOS. WE PLAYED HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL AND CONTINUED
ON TO PLAY DEFENSIVE TACKLE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF SAN FRANCISCO
AND SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY HE WENT ON TO SIGN A
CONTRACT. WITH THE CANADIAN
FOOTBALL LEAGUE AND TRIED OUT
FOR THE DALLAS COWBOYS. UPON
THE END OF HIS FOOTBALL CAREER
BILL WENT ON TO A DISTINGUISHED
BUSINESS CAREER AND EVENTUAL
RUN FOR THE STATE ASSEMBLY
WORRY REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
THROUGHOUT THE PENINSULA MADE
FRIENDS ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE. AND HAPPENED TO BE THE
LAST REPUBLICAN ELECTED TO
PARTISAN OFFICE. IN STEM MATTEO
COUNTING. FOLLOWING HIS. FAMILY
BILL WENT ON TO BECOME JUST
LATER THAT THE CAT. IN THE
SECOND AREA FOR NEARLY TWENTY
TWO YEARS WITH THE FIRM KLEIN
AND DUPLICITY. ALSO SERVED AS
ADMINISTRATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
STATE'S DIVISION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION A MEMBER OF THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION. DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF MANUFACTURING ROUTE
GEN. AT A PUBLIC FOR OF THE ARE
PATIENT ALL SAFETY. HE'LL
SUPPORT. WITHOUT A DOUBT BILL
SECURE THE RESPECT OF HIS
COLLEAGUES AND HIS CLIENTS BOTH
AS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER. AND AS A
LOBBYIST WITH HIS UNQUESTIONED
INTEGRITY. AND SELFLESS VIEWS
ON MAJOR POLICY ISSUES. BUT IT
WAS HIS PERSONA A QUICK
DISARMING SMILE. THAT DEEP
BOOMING VOICE THAT CARRIED
GRAVITAS BUT WAS WELCOMING AT
THE SAME TIME. A TOWERING
FIGURE HE HAD JUST THE RIGHT
MIX OF AUTHORITATIVE SWAGGER.
MATCH WITH KINDNESS AND
GENTILITY. HE WAS SUCH A
DISTINCTIVE FIGURE. WITH HIS
DAPPER SUITS SUSPENDERS AND
TOPPED OFF WITH THAT FEDORA HAT
IT'S ACTUALLY DIFFICULT TO
IMAGINE THAT THERE EVER BEING
ANOTHER BILL TO PLEASE SEE.
HE'S CALIFORNIA ORIGINAL. HIS
YEARS OF PUBLIC SERVICE
REPRESENT TENTATIVE COUNTY AS
ADVOCATES ARE CAN BE REGION
STATE. WILL NOT BE FORGOT. THE
SERVER I BY IS WONDERFUL SHARON.
HIS CHORE AND ELEANOR AND BILL
HIS GRANDCHILDREN GRACE AND
BILLY AND HIS SISTER CAROL
MEMBERS I ASKED TODAY THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY. OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL THE POLICY.
THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN MISTER
GIVE SEND YOU WILL BE
RECOGNIZED IN THE FRONT OF THE
CHAMBERS WHILE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS. I
MAY BE ABLE TO PLAY THREE.
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO BOTH OF
THE CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR THE
SEAT THAT I NOW OCCUPIED. BILL
MADE. AN INDELIBLE IMPRESSION
UPON MY LIFE. HE WAS STOOD AS A
GIANT BUT SOMEONE WHO'S ALWAYS
WITH CRYING TO ME. I LEARNED
THAT BILL WAS HOSPITALIZED
WITHIN SENSE FROM THEIR MOVE TO
A NURSING FACILITY. I ASKED
STEPHANIE MARKET VISIT HIM SHE
SAID NO BECAUSE OF PUBLIC
NINETEEN. I ASKED HER IF I CAN
CALL THE- SISTER THAT POSSIBLY
MAY NOT BE POSSIBLE. I SAID
WELL IF CAN I WRITE A LETTER
AND COULD YOU READ THAT LETTER
TO FOR ME. SHE SAID I'LL BE
HAPPY TO. THE LETTER STARTED
OFF BY SAYING HEY BILL. I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE NOT FEELING
TOO WELL. ALTHOUGH I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE CIRCUMSTANCES.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
LEAVES YOU HEARD FROM ME. ON
MAY TWENTY FIRST ON THIS FLOOR.
ON THE CALIFORNIA GREEN CARPET.
I NOTICED A BILL TO PLACE HE
WAS IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBERS.
IT WAS DURING A BMP MEETING A
HEARING. ONCE THE HEARING WAS
OVER WIT AND BILLS ITEM WAS
VOTED OFF THE FLOOR VOTER OUT.
I WALKED TO THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER AND YOU GO BILL. HOW
DOES IT FEEL TO BE ON THE GREEN
CARPET ONCE AGAIN. BILL TURNED
AROUND WITH A HUGE INFECTIOUS
SMILE ANY SAID MIKE IT FELT
GOOD. NO IT FELT GREAT TO BE
BACK ON THE GREEN CARPET. I
THEIR TURN TO MEMBER EVAN LOW
AND WE REFLECTED SHIRLEY
THEREAFTER. DIDN'T TAKE HIS
BILL THE PLACE PLEASE SMILE AS
HE WALKED OUT THE DOOR. HE HAD
THAT GRIN. I NEVER KNEW THAT
THE LAST TIME THAT I WAS THE-
BILL THE PLACING. WHAT I CALL
MY FRIEND. IF THE BILL TO
PLEASE THE WITH UNLIKE OTHER
LOBBYIST HERE IN GRACE BEING.
HE SPOKE TO ME IN. HE MADE ME
FEEL. LIKE I WAS CLOSER THAN
ANYONE IN HIS FAMILY. ALSO
WROTE IN A LETTER BILL YOUR
LIFE IS LIKE A FOOTBALL. GAME.
IS THE BILL WOULD YOU HAVE RAN
THE FINAL TOUCHDOWN. AND HE
SCORED POINTS ALL THE BOARD.
THE CODE TO REALIZE THAT YOU'RE
TIRED AND TAKE YOU OUT OF THE
GAME SO YOU CAN REST. BILL THE
COACHES YOU OUT. JUST SO YOU
CAN REST BILL YOU'LL
CONTINUOUSLY BE MY FRIEND
RESTAURANT. GOD BLESS YOU BILL
THE POLICY THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL NOW WITH THE CALL BEFORE
WE MOVED TO FURTHER
ENCHANTMENTS IN MEMORY. A.
MOVING TO THE NEXT THE GERMAN
IN MEMORY MISS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE GERMAN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS AFTERNOON I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF HENRY HANK DEAL OF BURBANK.
FOR DECADES HANK WAS APPROVED
PROLIFIC COMMUNITY SERVICE WHO
PLAYED AN ACTIVE ROLE IN THE
BURBANK COMMUNITY. HE WAS A
VIBRANT AND ACTIVE EIGHTY THREE
VETERAN LOVING HUSBAND FATHER
GRANT IN A COMMUNITY MEMBER.
HIS DEDICATION TO BURBANK KNEW
NO BOUNDS HE SERVED AS A BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE BURBANK
COORDINATING COUNCIL
VOLUNTEERED WITH BIKE ANGELS
BURBANK SENIOR CITIZEN BOARD.
THE BURBANK ADVISORY COUNCIL ON
DISABILITIES AMBER BANKS
VETERANS COMMUTE COMMITTEE. AS
A MEMBER OF THE BURBANK HUMAN
RELATIONS COUNCIL HE TRANSPORT
OF HOLOCAUST SURVIVORS TO SPEAK
AT SCHOOLS. MARCH FOR HUMAN
RIGHTS. GUN CONTROL LEGISLATION
AND WORKED ON KINDERTRANSPORT
PROGRAMMING ANNUALLY. AS A
KOREAN WAR VETERAN HE WAS ALSO
ACTIVE IN THE DISABLED AMERICAN
VETERANS AMERICAN LEGION AND
VETERANS OF FOREIGN WARS. THIS
WORLD AND OUR COMMUNITY IS SO
MUCH EMPTIER NOW WITHOUT HIM IN
IT. HOWEVER HIS SPIRIT AND
LEGACY WILL LIVE ON IN THE
HEARTS OF THE COUNTLESS LIVES
HE HAS TOUCHED. I HUMBLY ASK
THAT WE EXTEND OUR HEARTFELT
CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE JANET.
THEIR FIVE CHILDREN. HIS
SIBLINGS AND GRANDSON THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN. MR GIPSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR NEXT TO
GERMAN IN MEMORY. MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE THAT HIS
BODY TO JOURNEY THE MEMORY
RAFEAL FLEMING BROOKS OF CARSON
SHE WAS BORN AUGUST TWENTY
FOURTH NINETEEN THIRTY. OF
NINETEEN THIRTY FOUR AND
HOSTAGE IN TEXAS AND WAS ONE OF
NINE CHILDREN. MS BROOKS. MOST
HUMAN COMMUNITY CALLED MISS
BROOKS I CALLER SISTER BROOKS
ATTENDED- TEXAS- SOUTHERN
UNIVERSITY AND MAJOR INDUSTRIAL
EDUCATION SHE WAS MARRIED TO
POLICY BROOKS AND BOTH- HAD TWO
BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN- AFTER A
MOVE FROM TEXAS TO CARSON
CALIFORNIA. WHERE SHE WAS JOIN
THE OPINION WELL MISSIONARY
BAPTIST CHURCH TO FIFTEEN EAST
A HUNDRED A STREET BETWEEN
STAMPEDE REMAIN HE ALSO FOUNDED
THE YOUTH DEPARTMENT THAT I WAS
A MEMBER OF GROWING UP. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE. AND
INSPIRATIONAL SISTERHOOD PRIOR
SPONSORED BY THE WOMEN'S
FEDERATION OF WORLD PEACE WHERE
SHE RECEIVED A CERTIFICATE OF
RECOGNITION. AND THE OFFICIAL
PARTNERSHIP PARTNER IN PEACE
CARD SHE WILL ALSO WAS A FREE
FOR I'LL W. MEMBER LATER SHE
WOULD BE RECOGNIZED FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND CHARITABLE WORK
IN THE CITY OF CARSON RECEIVING
COUNTLESS RESOLUTIONS AND
RECOGNITION. FROM THE LATE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN JENNY OR PAYS
OUT AND ALSO SENATOR FORMER
STATE SENATOR DEBBIE BONE AND
SUPERVISOR YVONNE BRATHWAITE
BURKE MISS BROOKS SISTER BROOKS
WAS ALWAYS FULL OF LIFE AND A
HARD WORKER NOT TO MENTION A
FANTASTIC COOK- HER LEGACY AND
HER MEMORY WILL LIVE ON IN THE
HEARTS AND MINDS. WE PRAY FOR
HER AMILY AND RELATIVES AND
THANK THEM FOR SHARING SUCH A
WONDERFUL PERSON WITH ALL OF US
ROUGH L. BROOKS. THANK YOU
MISTER DAVIS AND MISTER WOULD
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
TERM THE MEMORY. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TO JOIN IN THE MEMORY OF
BERRY STERLING THE CO FOUNDER
OF IRON HORSE VINEYARDS. VERY
FOLLOWING HIS DREAMS UNTIL WE
LEFT THIS WORLD ON JULY TWENTY
SIX SURROUNDED BY FAMILY A LIFE
WELL LIVED. HE PASSED AT AGE
NINETY. HIS DREAM TOOK AN
INDIRECT ROUTE HE GRADUATED
FROM HEART OF STANFORD LAW
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO IN
THE SAME CLASSES FUTURE SUPREME
COURT JUSTICES AND FRIENDS.
WILLIAM REHNQUIST IN SANDRA DAY
O'CONNOR. THAT SAME YEAR HE
PASSED THE BAR MARRIED HIS WIFE
AUDREY AND BEGAN HIS CAREER
WITH THE ARMY. NEWLYWEDS WE'VE
MOVED TO CHARLOTTESVILLE
VIRGINIA AND THEN TO WASHINGTON
DC. TWO YEARS LATER THE COUPLE
MOVED TO LOS ANGELES AND
STERLING OPEN HIS OWN LAW FIRM.
BUT THEN THE FORK IN THE ROAD.
SPURRED THEIR BY SPURRED BY
THEIR TRAVELS TO EUROPE IN HIS
LOVE AND APPRECIATION OF WINE.
THEY MOVED TO FRANCE IN
NINETEEN SIXTIES AND- LEADING
TO THE OF LIVING ON A VINEYARD
MAKING WINE. IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY STE IN AND DRIVING
RAINSTORM HERE AUDREY BUTTE
EIGHTEEN CENTURY CARP GOTHIC
HOUSE NEAR SEBASTOPOL. LEVINE
PLANTED IN OWN BY RIDE EAST BUT
AN ARRAY. IF IN LOVE WITH THE
PROPER AND HAVE TAKE TURNS MADE
FROM GRAPES HE KNEW THIS WAS
WHERE HIS WITH. DESPITE WHAT
THE EXPERTS TOLD THEM ABOUT THE
CLIMATE BEING TOO CHILLY FOR
THE CHARDONNAY AND PINOT NOIR
GRAPES. HE PURCHASED THE
PROPERTY ANYWAY. AN OPEN NINE
HORSE BEEN YEARS IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. IRONHORSE WINDS
HAVE BEEN SERVED AT FORMAL
DINNERS BY SIX PRESIDENTS
INCLUDING A SUMMIT BETWEEN
FORMER PRESIDENT REAGAN. AND
SOVIET AND SOVIET LEADER
MIKHAIL GORBACHEV IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. THERE WAS ALSO A
PATRON OF THE ARTS A POLITICAL
ACTIVISTS AN ART COLLECTOR AND
PHILANTHROPIST A WORLD TRAVELER
AND A MASTER GARDENER. HE
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO SYMPHONY WAS A
LIFETIME TRUSTEE OF THE LEAKY
FOUNDATION. IN ADDITION TO
POURING IN HIGH PLACES. IRON
HORSE ALSO BOTTLES A SPECIAL
GROUP NAY WITH NATIONAL
GEOGRAPHIC CALLED OCEAN RESERVE
WHICH SUPPORTS POTION
CONSERVATION AN ADVANTAGE GROUP
CALLED GRATITUDE THE BENEFITS
THE REDWOOD EMPIRE FOOD BANK.
HE AND HIS WIFE AUDREY WOULD
HAVE CELEBRATED THEIR SIXTIETH
WEDDING ANNIVERSARY THIS MONTH.
IN A TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
INTERVIEW BERRY SAID OUR LIFE
IS GREAT WE'VE HAD A VERY GOOD
RUN. EVERYONE KNOWS US KNOWS
WE'VE HAD A HELL OF A GOOD TIME.
VERY IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
AUDREY. THE CHILDREN JOY
LAWRENCE AND TERRY. FOUR
GRANDCHILDREN ONE GREAT
GRANDSON FIVE NIECES AND
NEPHEWS. WAS AN HONOR TO GET TO
KNOW BERRY AND I'M HONORED
TODAY TO JOIN A DETERRENT IN
MEMORY. OF PERRY STERLING THANK
YOU MISTER WHERE MEMBERS PLEASE
BRING THE NAME THREE DEATHS WE
PRINTED THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND THEN THE
JOURNAL. MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS OUR GUEST WORK
WITH CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
AUGUST FIFTH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY AUGUST SIXTH CHECK IN
SESSION AND FRIDAY AUGUST
SEVENTH NO FLOOR SESSION FOR
CHECK IN SESSION ALL OTHER
ITEMS REMAINING WE PASSED THE
RETAINED ON OCEAN SHALL BE
CONTINUED. SEEING AND HEARING
NO FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY
TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO
ADJOURN MR BONTA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY
AUGUST SEVENTEENTH AT ONE PM.
LARA. RAMOS VOTE CHANGE ON AB.
THREE TWO THREE FOUR. FROM I TO
NOT VOTING. MODE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS SENATE
BILL THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR I
TO NOT LOADING.